monsieur le Président chers collègues
deux points sont inscrits à l'ordre du
jour de notre réunion de ce matin nous
entendrons d'abord monsieur lucrémont
président directeur général du groupe
EDF puis Charles Fournier et Sandra
Marceau nous présenteront leur rapport
d'information sur les incidences du
déploiement des grands entrepôts
logistiques monsieur le président
Raymond votre audition intervient
quelques jours après celle d'agè
panierunaché ministre de la transition
énergétique que nous avons reçu le 29
novembre dernier ces deux auditions ont
pour objet principal de nous permettre
de mieux comprendre les tenants et les
aboutissants de l'accord trouvé entre le
gouvernement et EDF sur les grandes
lignes du nouveau mécanisme de
régulation des prix de l'électricité
d'origine nucléaire qui doit succéder à
l'accès régulé de l'électricité
nucléaire historique à savoir
l'AREN la ministre nous a indiqué que
cet accord estabiré un juste équilibre
entre trois impératifs le maintien de la
compétitivité de notre industrie la
stabilisation des prix pour les ménage
et la capacité deedf de poursuivre son
développement et ses investissements
monsieur le Président par partagez-vous
cette appréciation notamment en ce qui
concerne la couverture de vos
investissements et puis s'agissant de la
préservation de la compétitivité de nos
entreprises et plus particulièrement des
électrointensives pourriez-vous nous
fournir des explications peut-être un
peu plus détaillées sur les contrats de
partenariat de long terme je crois
savoir à peu près 5 ans que cet accord
vous autoriserit à proposer à la fois
pour les gros mais peut-être aussi pour
les moins gros pouvez-vous rassurer nos
chefs d'entreprise qui expriment une
demande de prévisibilité dans un monde
où la localisation des industries
fortement guidé par le prix de l'énergie
il est essentiel que nos entreprises
puissent disposer d'un tel atout
monsieur le Président sans plus attendre
vous avez la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci de votre invitation
mesdames et messieurs les
députés bonjour et ravi d'être parmi
vous pour évoquer ces sujets qui sont
essentiels pour pour notre énergie et
donc notre économie je vais peut-être
commencer en quelques mots par vous
parler de la situation opérationnelle de
DF et et du passage de l'hiver puisque
nous sommes au début de l'hiver et vous
évidemment vous avez tous en mémoire le
passage de l'hiver dernier qui était
critique difficile euh et je suis
heureux de vous dire que après un énorme
travail de l'ensemble des équipes de DF
et de l'ensemble de la filière
industrielle qui travaille avec nous
nous abordons ce nouvel hiver avec
beaucoup plus de sérénité euh grâce à
une maîtrise du problème de corrosion
sous contrainte auquel nous avons été
confrontés depuis le début de l'année
2022 et une accélération industriel de
son traitement nous avons à aujourd'hui
44 GW de production nucléaire en en
production euh avec un disponible de 45
euh j'ai regardé ce matin à 4h du matin
nous avions 18 GW excédentairire par
rapport aux besoins du pays euh dont 2,5
étaient sous forme de stockage le reste
sous forme d'export ça ça donne
simplement la la mesure de du retour à
une disponibilité qui est équivalent
désormais à ce que nous avions avant le
phénomène de corrosion sous contrainte
même s'il nous reste évidemment à
continuer d'améliorer la disponibilité
du parc dans le temps en continuant de
travailler sur la pérénisation de nos
activités mais ça se fait désormais dans
le cadre de la programmation naturelle
de et normale de la maintenance du parc
nous nous avons également une forte
disponibilité de
l'hydroélectricité toute la pluie qui
tombe remplit les lacs et donc nous
avons un niveau de remplissage
hydroélectrique qui est supérieur à la
moyenne sur cette année ce qui concourt
également
à la disponibilité pour le passage de
l'hiver et
enfin le niveau de consommation
électrique reste faible puisque l'effort
de sobriété est maintenu de la part de
l'ensemble de nos citoyen euh à un
niveau estimé de 8 à 9 % par rapport aux
consommations des années précédentes
voilà tout ceci concourt donc au fait
que nous puissions passer l'hiver euh
avec aborder l'hiver avec sérénité même
si évidemment l'attention à la fois
opérationnel sur le fait de produire euh
dans les temps et dans les bonnes
quantités et sur la sobriité reste
maintenu nous serons au rendez-vous de
l'objectif de production que nous avions
fixé pour cette année dans la fourchette
de 300 à 330 terraw alors pour revenir
sur sur votre question principale
monsieur le Président sur l'accord
conclu avec le gouvernement sur le futur
de la régulation des prix en tout cas
pour ce qui concerne la production
nucléaire de DF bien je voudrais d'abord
dire qu'il nous fallait trouver inventer
quelque chose de nouveau parce que le
système dans lequel nous sommes depuis
2012 j'avais l'occasion de le dire dès
ma première audition devant votre votre
commission pour l'audition article 13 ce
système était à bout de souffle il était
à bout de souffle pour plusieurs raisons
la première c'est que en fondant une
part importante de la formation des prix
sur une décision de prix
administré portant sur en réalité les 2
tiers de la production nucléaire deedf
cela fixait des conditions économiques
pour EDF qui n'étaient pas soutenable
dans la durée et la deuxième c'est que
l'apparence de protection que donnait
Laar sur les prix de l'électricité en
réalité comme la reine laissait une
grande part
d'exposition à l'évolution des prix de
court terme des prix spot de court terme
de marché en fait la protection pour les
clients n'était pas suffisante face à un
phénomène tel que celui que nous avons
rencontré depuis 2022 qui est une
explosion généralisée des prix de marché
consécutifs à la guerre donc le système
était arrivé à bout de sououfle il nous
fallait inventer quelque chose d'autre
et c'est cela qui a pris un peu de temps
et nous avons travaillé main dans la
main avec avec évidemment le
gouvernement mais également avec les
parties prenantes industrielles que vous
citiez pour trouver le meilleur
dispositif possible qui nous permett
d'atteindre les objectifs que vous avez
cité c'est-à-dire la compétitivité pour
l'industrie la stabilité pour nos
concitoyens particuliers et puis
évidemment la
nécessité essentielle pour EDF à ce
stade d'investir à nouveau pour être
capable d'assurer une fourniture pérenne
d'électricité alors ce dispositif tel
que nous l'avons conçu et et qui a fait
l'objet d'un accord il repose sur des
principes qui sont assez simples le
premier principe c'est que dans la
droite ligne des discussions européennes
qui sont en cours et qui tirent toutes
les leçons de la crise énergétique que
nous traversons nous nous nous tirons
d'abord le le commerce vers le long
terme et tirer le commerce vers le long
terme c'est essentiel pour aller vers la
stabilité je vais illustrer mon propos
en disant que
depuis depuis le mois de septembre EDF a
pris l'initiative de vendre de
l'électricité aux horizons de 2027 et
2028 ça n'était pas fait jusqu'à présent
et et en partie le dispositif de laaren
nous désincitait à faire
ça en vendant notre électricité en 2027
et 2028 nous formons des prix
d'électricité qui sont entre 68 et 78 €
du mgawh pour ces deux années-là et donc
très très en dessous des prix de cette
année et de l'année prochaine alors que
il n'y a aucune certitude sur le fait
qu'en 2027 et 2028 nous serons sortis de
la crise ukrainienne par exemple mais le
fait de vendre à cet horizon de temps
qui est long naturellement fait
converger les prix vers une estimation
qui est faite par les acheteurs comme
par les producteurs de ce que sont les
conditions normales de l'économie donc
ce le seul fait de tirer long dans
l'électricité comme dans tous les
marchés de commodité amène à une
convergence naturelle vers les
fondamentaux de l'économie de
l'électricité et donc nous sommes d'ors
et déjà quand on nous vendant de
l'électricité à cet horizon de temps
nous sommes d'ors et déjà dans des
gammes de prix qui sont autour du fameux
70 € du mgawh en moyenne qui est
l'estimation des prix de que sur
lesquels nous pouvons compter sur le
moyen terme comme étant une référence
stable donc c'est le premier élément
c'est le commerce de long terme et le
premier facteur de stabilisation et ce
facteur de stabilisation il est bon pour
les clients parce que il donne de la
stabilité sur leurs conditions d'accès à
électricité mais il est également bon
pour le producteur et l'investisseur qui
est EDF puisque'en ayant cette
visibilité à long terme EDF est capable
de compter sur davantage de stabilité
sur ces conditions de ressources et donc
de s'engager davantage sur des
conditions d'investissement donc c'est
le premier élément cet élément n'était
pas suffisant évidemment puisqu'il
fallait donner à nos clients à à nos
concitoyens des garanti en cas
d'évolution structurelle du marché sur
lequel évidemment ni EDF ni même l'État
n'a de prise puisque nous sommes dans un
marché européen qui peut lui aussi à
nouveau subir des aléas importants et
donc c'est pour faire face à ce type
d'évolution que nous avons conclu un un
accord sur des conditions à partir
desquelles les reven de DF serait capté
par l'État pour pouvoir être redistribué
directement au clients afin de les
protéger en cas d'évolution
structurel des prix vers le haut et donc
c'est ce qui nous a conduit à un premier
seuil de captation estimé à 78 à 80 € du
mgawh de 2022 au-delà duquel 50 % des
revenus excédentaires au-delà de ces
seuils seraient capté par le par l'État
pour être redistribué aux clients
directement que les clients soient des
clients de F ou des concurrents du D
bien sûr et puis un deuxième seuil
au-delà de 110 € du mgawh au-delà duquel
90 % des revenus qui serait dégagé par
le parc historique de DF serait capté
pour être redistribué au clients et donc
ce dispositif là il est protecteur et il
est plus protecteur que la reine en cas
de prix haut puisqu'il capte la
totalité des revenus généré par le parc
historique de DF et pas seulement une
partie donc le le dispositif il est fait
d'un commerce de long terme qui permet
de lisser naturellement les prix et de
les faire converger vers la réalité
économique de l'électricité en donnant à
la fois de la stabilité pour les clients
et une capacité d'investissement pour
EDF et puis d'un dispositif protecteur
qui vient compléter le commerce de long
terme pour pour protéger les clients en
cas de hausse structurelle des prix
voilà comment ce dispositif est conçu
alors pour revenir sur vos questions
monsieur le Président sur notamment sur
industrie et bien euh nous parlons
aujourd'hui de gamme de prix à horizon
2728 qui sont qui sont très très
nettement inférieur à ce que payent
aujourd'hui les entreprises quel que
soit leur taille on parle à peu près de
la moitié de ce qu'elles payent voire
même voire même moins de la moitié
puisque sur l'année 2023 qui est une
année évidemment exceptionnelle la
plupart des entreprises payent plutôt
entre 200 et 300 € du mgaw la fourniture
d'électricité et ceci c'est simplement
le résultat de l'explosion des prix de
court terme consécutive de de
la de de la crise en Ukraine donc
naturellement nous allons converger vers
des prix beaucoup plus faibles pour les
entreprises le deuxième phénomène que je
voudrais souligner c'est que depuis que
cet accord a été annoncé éidemment le
fait que nous ayons annoncé qu'il y aura
à cet horizon de temps 26 27 28 beaucoup
plus d'électricité disponible de façon
marchande ça a détendu considérablement
euh les euh la la la perspective de de
la demande d'avoir la disponibilité de
l'électricité cela a contribué en tant
que tel c'est pas le seul phénomène mais
ça a contribué à détendre les prix de
plus de 10 % depuis que l'accord a été
annoncé et ça a contribué à un autre
phénomène c'est que euh le prix français
est repassé en dessous du prix allemand
euh sur ces horizons de temps donc
aujourd'hui sur ces horizons de temps
nous avons 10 € d'écart par rapport au
prix allemand sur cet horizon de temps
donc l'ensemble de ces éléments la
disponibilité de l'électricité pour être
acheté de façon marchande par les
entreprises notamment et sur le marché
de gros et puis le fait que nous
donnions la clarteté sur la
disponibilité deélectricité à cet
horizon de temps contribue à détendre
les prix et naturellement eDF va
s'engager massivement et déjà engagé
massivement pour commercer à long terme
que ce soit avec les clients ou avec les
fournisseurs d'électricité que nous
considérons comme des clients bien sûr
euh que nous fournirons sur le marché de
gros voilà les éléments principaux
ensuite il y a des situations évidemment
particulières de certains types
d'entreprise ou certains types de de
clientèle que nous allons évidemment
adresser de façon spécifique vous avez
mentionné les électrointensifs euh les
électrointensifs évidemment peuvent
avoir des besoins qui ne sont pas traité
par ce marché de 5 ans euh parce qu'ils
ont besoin d'horizon d'encore plus long
terme pour déterminer leurs conditions
d'investissement et pour déterminer
leurs conditions de compétitivité à plus
long terme donc pour les
électrointensifs nous nous avons une
approche partenarial dans
lequel une entreprise peut vouloir
souhaiter passer un accord de quasi
coinvestissement avec EDF pour obtenir
finalement un un un droit de
récupération de production qui est
presque équivalent à ce qu'ils auraient
s'ils avaient investi dans une capacité
de production électrique et ça ça leur
donne accès à une électricité qui est
encore plus compétitive parce qu'elle se
rapproche des conditions d'un producteur
d'électricité et donc nous avons des
discussions avec un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui sont qui sont fondés
sur ce type d'approche partenariale et
qui avanceent bien euh voilà voilà ce
que je voulais dire dernier mot sur les
sur les particuliers qui était votre
votre troisième question nous avons
évidemment eu le souci dans toute cette
discussion de pouvoir assurer la
stabilité des prix pour les particuliers
alors sur 2024 et 2025 nous sommes
toujours sous le régime Aren donc le
tarif réglementé de vente évidemment
sera maintenu au-delà de l'horizon 2025
il sera même étendu comme l'ont annoncé
les ministres à aux très petites
entreprises au-delà de 36 kV qui était
un des seuils
techniques qui qui ne permettait pas à
certaines très petites entreprises de
pouvoir accéder aux conditions du tarif
donc ça sera étendu à l'ensemble des
très petites entreprises en parfaite
conform é avec avec ce que prévoient les
textes européens et donc les conditions
de ce tarif seront maintenu au-delà de
2026 sur 20424 et 2025 les conditions du
tarif relèvent toujours de l'application
du régime Aren au-delà de 2026 nous
aurons évidemment le même phénomène de
lissage qui permettra de de de faire
rejoindre sans couture le dispositif
actuel et le dispositif futur avec une
stabilité des prix euh pour l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens au-delà de cet
horizon voilà l'objectif de qui a été
poursuivi dans dans dans cet accord et
sur lequel nous sommes engagés chez EDF
à faire en sorte que cet accord
réussisse dernière question sur les
investissements est-ce que cet accord
nous permet d'investir ben je je je vais
vous dire la même chose que ce que je
dis aux équipes de DF c'est ça nous
permet d'investir si nous sommes bons
euh c'està que c'est un accord qui nous
qui nous responsabilise en tant
qu'entreprise nous devons être bon
commerçant et un commerçant responsable
faire en sorte que nous proposions à
l'ensemble de nos clients et aux
concurrents qui souhaiteront nous
achetter de
l'électricité des bonnes conditions
d'électricité pour du commerce de long
terme nous devons être un bon industriel
qui produit beaucoup et nous devons être
un bon investisseur qui réalise bien ses
projets à ces conditionsl nous
réussirons mais ce qui est sain c'est
que ça met EDF en situation de
responsabilité dans des conditions de
jeu qui sont des conditions de jeu
d'entreprise et je pense qu'en ce à ce
titre c'est un accord qui est qui est
tout à fait bénéfique pour faire en
sorte que tout le monde ait envie de
faire réussir euh voilà ce que je
voulais dire sur sur vos questions
monsieur le Président alors il y a
évidemment beaucoup de travail à faire
pour mettre en œuvre cet accord et ça
commence bien sûr par engager la
totalité de nos nos clients et puis
également évidemment nos nos nos
concurrents fournisseurs qui souhaitent
avoir l'électricité de de DF parmi leur
portefeuille d'électricité pour faire en
sorte que le moyen terme c'est-à-dire
les 5 ans deviennent un élément
classique euh de commerce de
l'électricité parce que c'est le facteur
d'atterrissage le plus
important des prix et c'est ce qui nous
permettra de stabiliser le plus euh les
horizons de prix vers euh ce qui est
nécessaire pour les économie
d'électricité à moyen terme voilà ce que
je peux vous dire euh monsieur le
Président en terme d'introduction je
veux pas être beaucoup plus long en
terme d'introduction il y a énormément
de sujets bien sûr mais je pense que le
mieux c'est que je réponde aux questions
je sais que votre commission a toujours
une cadence précise sur les questions et
donc je pense qu'on peut on peut laisser
du temps aux questions merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président vous n connaissez
bien maintenant donc nous allons passer
aux orateurs de groupe pour chaque
orateur de groupe donc 4 minutes inclus
votre temps de réponse et on va jusqu'à
maximum 3 minutes si vous souhaitez
faire un propos d'une traite on commence
tout de suite avec Antoine Armand pour
le groupe Renaissance c'est à
vous merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Directeur Général
de DF je voudrais d'abord bien sûr
commencer par saluer le principe de
l'accord qui a été trouvé entre notre
gouvernement et l'entreprise EDF qui
poursuit vous l'avez rappelé trois
objectifs essentiels et vitaux le
premier c'est bien sûr la poursuite des
tarifs réglementés de vente et leur
extension à toutes les TPE quel que soit
le seuil on a vu à quel point c'était
important pendant la crise que nous
avons traversé le deuxième c'est bien
sûr la mise en place d'un mécanisme de
prix qui doit éviter de replonger
replonger dans les affres de la crise
énergétique que nous avons connu avec
des prix du mgaw qui ont sérieusement
attaquer notre tissu industriel et le
troisième objectif bien sûr c'est la la
préservation de la rentabilité et de la
capacité d'investissement deedf qui sera
le principal porteur de la relance
absolument inédite du nucléaire annoncé
par par le Président de la République
c'est un accord nécessaire c'est un
accord qui va succéder à l'arène que
nous avions sur tous les bancs ici de
cette assemblée tous ensemble lors de la
commission d'enquête sur la souveraineté
énergétique dénoncer et avec certains
effectivement de de longues dates comme
je l'entends derrière moi euh c'est un
accord qui nécessite bien sûr et c'est
l'objet de de votre audition aujourd'hui
d'être expliqué d'être détaillé qui
suscite de nouvelles questions
extrêmement importantes et puis des
questions sur ses modalités et sur son
calendrier quel prix de l'électricité
nos compatriotes peuvent-ils s'attendre
à trouver sur leur facture quel type
d'offres vont être proposé à nos
entreprises hyper électrointensive le
président de la commission l'a rappelé
mais aussi les petites entreprises qui
elles aussi peuvent avoir une partie de
leur chiffre d'affaires substantiel en
en prix de l'électricité comment sera
construit le prix de référence qui doit
et c'est heureux enfin refléter les
coûts de production d'EDF quel est le
niveau de productible qui est nécessaire
d'être attendu par EDF pour que l'accord
soit à la fois rentable pour EDF et
profitable à l'ensemble de notre tissu
industriel enfin sur combien d'années le
tissu économique disposera-t-il de
visibilité parce que le prix est bien
sûr une question fondamentale eu et mais
ceux qui ont investis dans notre pays le
font sur une durée bien supérieure à
quelques mois à ces questions monsieur
le Président Directeur Général j'ai bien
conscience qu'il nous faudra ensemble
apporter des réponses c'est l'objet du
futur projet de loi de souveraineté
énergétique annoncé par la ministre et
pour réussir je le dis à l'ône des 150
heures d'audition que nous avons mené
collectivement avec plusieurs d'entre
vous contrairement aux 30 dernières
années nous ne pourrons faire EDF ni
d'un totem auquel nous devons tout
passer pour lequel nous devons pas
regarder ni la performance industrielle
ni la rentabilité ni un tabou qu'on
serait tenté de sacrifier à l'ône de
d'ermement de politique énergétique nous
vous remercions donc monsieur le
Président des premiers éléments que vous
pourrez nous communiquer merci beaucoup
Monsieur Armand monsieur le Président
merci beaucoup monsieur le député
Armand merci pour vos encouragements et
et je suis le premier bien qu' reste
énormément de travail évidemment pour
faire vivre cet
accord parce que il nous fallait changer
de paradigme et je crois que cet accord
permet de le faire de façon soutenable à
la fois pour nos concitoyens nos
entreprises et pour
EDF et je tiens d'ailleurs à remercier
le travail du Parlement et notamment le
travail de la commission dont don vous
avez été le rapporteur qui qui a aidé au
constat qui a permis ce changement de
paradigme parce qu'il a un moment lors
d'une précédente audition j'avais dit
qu'il nous fallait créer un nouveau
consensus national créer un nouveau
consensus national ça nécessite
évidemment l'implication la mobilisation
du Parlement et je vous en remercie vous
avez évidemment nommé des questions
précises qui nécessiterait des longs
développements je vais essayer d'y
répondre dans les 20 secondes qui me
reste
donc euh au fond il restera un prix de
l'électricité qui reste le résultat d'un
mécanisme de marché l'objectif c'est de
tirer ce prix le plus long possible vers
le long terme parce que c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui stabilise le plus le 70 €
du mégawh qui a été la référence et le
résultat de j'ose dire dizaines de
milliers de simulations sur les
conditions dans lesquelles la formation
du prix peut se faire à moyen terme et
dans des conditions soutenables et en
mettant des gardesfous si les prix
montent plus haut c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué avec la captation au-delà de 78
€ du mgawh mais en laissant la
responsabilité aux opérateurs de
commercer pour stabiliser les prix et
c'est ça l'élément fondamental de cet
accord qui nous faudra j'en ai bien
conscience continuer d'expliquer et de
faire vivre merci beaucoup pour le
rassemblement national c'est
Jean-Philippe Tangi qui porte la parole
de son groupe c'est à
vous appuyer sur le bouton
voilà merci monsieur le Président
bonjour Monsieur Raymond écoutez une
partie de la réponse que vous venez
d'apporter à notre collègue traduit en
fait la problématique à laquelle nous
faisons face vous l'avez dit c'est
toujours un mécanisme de marché l'Union
européenne ses consommateurs ses
entreprises et ses gouvernements sont
toujours soumis aux règles de marché
pour ce qui concerne l'électricité et
donc aucune leçon n' en réalité été
tenue des 20 ans pour l'Union européenne
30 ans pour la sphère occidentale de
l'erreur de considérer l'électricité
comme un bien commercial ordinaire qu'on
peut échanger sur des marchés qui ont
fait preuve de leur totale faillite
quant à la gestion de l'intérêt général
et en particulier de d'un intérêt
national quant à la souveraineté
énergétique vous installez avec cette
audition que j'ai écouté attentivement
euh EDF dans une stratégie de prix élevé
que vous présentez comme des prix
compétitif tout simplement parce que
d'autres pays ont des prix encore plus
élevés mais moi je ne compare pas le
champion le service public ettait EDF
avec des entreprises prédatrices qui
n'ont jamais eu pour souci d'assurer une
énergie la moins chère possible à nos
compatriotes et à nos entreprises la
réalité que personne ne semble vouloir
traiter depuis que nous avons appris que
la creux estimé le prix de viient du
nucléaire à 70 % plus élevé que son prix
ancien c'est pourquoi a-t-on atteint un
prix aussi élevé euh madame panierunaché
m'a expliqué que c'était à cause de
l'entretien et de la mise en norme des
centrales en particulier po les
exigences post Fukushima bon j'ai
toujours pas compris en quoi les risques
que connaissait le Japon concernent la
France et donc on explique aux Français
que c'est à cause de cela ce qui n'avait
jamais été expliqué avant donc les
Français découvrent que des travaux qui
ont entrepris expliqueraient la dérive
des coûts dérive des coups qui est
systématique dans votre entreprise donc
la question en tant que défenseur du
contribuable et de l'usager que de ce
que devrait être les client de DF c'est
pourquoi une telle dérive des coûts
comment l'expliquez-vous comment la
justifiez-vous en particulier puisque
l'essentiel de votre parc de production
est un parc hérité est un parc amorti et
les travaux dont parlait madame panaché
n'expliquent pas le la dérive des que
cette dérive des coûts soit si
importante par rapport à des
investissements passés qui sont
totalement amortis la réalité je pense
et je voudrais vous interroger là-dessus
c'est que est-ce que oui ou non vous
vous intégrez dans une stratégie de prix
de l'énergie haut qui ne correspond pas
à des fondamentaux économique mais qui
qui correspond à une stratégie politique
qui consiste que pour imposer la
sobriété et en fait une économie de la
pénurie on explique aux gens qu'ils
doivent se priver et c'est en fait le
ressenti de nos compatriotes sur le
territoire c'est une partie des éléments
de langage du gouvernement même ils sont
ils sont atténués cette année et moi je
ne comprends pas comment on peut se
poser dans une telle perspective
l'énergie é bien de première nécess
c'est un bien vital c'est par ailleurs
le bien de la transition énergétique il
nous faut une électricité le plus bas
possible et quand le président de la
République promet une électricité au
coup de revient c'est sûr que c'est
facile de tenir une promesse si le coût
de production double donc moi les
promesses on explique aux gens qu'on va
tenir une promesse en doublant le prix
je pense pas que les Français acceptent
ce genre de dérivvees Tang on va laisser
quand même notre invité répondre allez-y
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
député Tangui je suis pas sûr que
j'arrive à vous convaincre des bienfaits
euh d'avoir la faculté d'échanger
d'électricité avec nos voisins mais euh
je peux simplement citer deux exemples
pendant les 25 dernières années nous
avons été exportateurs pendant 24 ans
euh et ce matin à 4h du matin nous
exportions et nous stockions 18 GW euh
ceux-ci sont des recettes pour le pays
euh l'année où nous avons eu un problème
industriel nous étions contents aussi de
pouvoir importer de l'électricité pour
faire en sorte que notre pays euh soit
euh soit euh dans la continuité
exploitation euh sur le prix de
l'électricité je pense qu'il est il est
abusif il est il est inexact de comparer
le 42 € du mgawh qui n'a jamais
correspondu au coût de DF c'était à une
décision administrative et les 70 € du
mgawh
d'aujourd'hui l'analyse des coûts elle
est liée au fait que nous avons un outil
industriel nous devons investir dans cet
outilindustriel un outil industriel
amorti dans lequel on ninvestit pas et
finit par s'arrêter donc nous nous avons
besoin d'investir dans notre outil
industriel pour qu'il assure la
continuité d'exploitation et le degré
d'investissement que nous devons faire
ne serait-ce que sur l'outil industriel
existant de production nucléaire et de 5
milliards d'euros par an donc soit nous
avons un modèle économique qui permet de
soutenir cet investissement de même que
l'investissement nécessair dans le futur
nucléaire qui est capable à terme de
remplacer ces outi industriel et nous
aurons une compétitivité pérenne nous
avons une électricité compétitive
aujourd'hui et nous l'aurons de façon
pine soit nous ne le faisons pas et un
jour nous n'aurons pas d'électricité
merci beaucoup pour le groupe la France
insoumis c'est Mathias Tavel qui porte
la parole de son
groupe merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le PDG vous avez un talent
certain et pour un électricien ce n'est
pas une petite affaire c'est d'arriver à
nous faire croire que des VC sont des
lanternes et vous venez encore d'en
faire la démonstration en expliquant que
on a besoin du marché pour importer ou
exporter de l'électricité alors que vous
savez pertinemment que la France
importait et exportait de l'électricité
avant la mise en place du marché
européen on pouvait donc le faire avant
le marché et on pourra donc le faire
après depuis que l'électricité est gérée
comme un bien marchant sur un marché
ouvert à la concurrence c'est simple ça
coûte plus cher 95 % d'augmentation du
prix du tarif réglementé de vente et ça
marche moins bien puisque notre pays n'a
probablement jamais été depuis la
Libération dans un état d'impréparation
énergétique tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
EDF n'en étant pas le seul responsable
je vous
l'accorde vous vous inscrivez dans une
fausse réforme de l'Union européenne qui
va continuer cette logique de marché et
qui vise même à supprimer les tarifs
réglementés de vente à terme ne les
tolérant que de façon transitoire pour
faire face à des crises l'accord que
vous avez conclu avec le gouvernement
est donc en quelque sorte un pansement
sur une jambe de bois il ne s'applique
qu'au nucléaire et et il permettra à EDF
de vendre jusqu'à 110 € le
mgawh une quasi totalité étant récupéré
par l'État au-delà de ce prix mais pas
en dessous on voit bien que cet accord
pant lui les germes d'une augmentation
forte des tarifs d'électricité onant
parler de 10 à 20 % ne serait-ce que
l'année prochaine mais c'est sans doute
bien au-delà pour la suite et ça pose de
nombreuses questions pourquoi avoir fait
une telle usine à gaz alors qu'on avait
historiquement dans notre pays un modèle
fondé sur un monopole public avec des
tarifs réglementés qui permettaient
d'éviter toutes ces constructions
acrobatique quelle est dans la hausse
des prix la part vraiment de hausse des
coûts de production et quelle est la
part qui relève en fait des prix de
marché déconnecté du coût moyen de
production toute énergie confondue
comment pouvez-vous garantir une
visibilité au consommateurs que ce soit
les entreprises ou les ménages alors
qu'en fait cet accord repose sur la
taxation de vos profit pour une
redistribution ensuite au consommateurs
sans qu'on sache ni à quel consommateur
ni par quel moyen ni dans quel montant
et plus globalement ne pensez-vous pas
qu'il faudrait tout simplement mettre en
cause ce fonctionnement de marché qu'il
faudrait interdire par exemple à des
fournisseurs alternatifs qui ne
produisent pas d'électricité d'être des
vendeurs d'électricité et réserver ce
droit à ceux qui ont vraiment des moyens
de production ne pensez-vous pas que les
mêmes contraintes et notamment la même
le même plafonnement des ressources
devrait s'appliquer à tous les
producteurs d'électricité et pas
seulement à EDF et enfin soutenez-vous
la suppression à terme des tarifs
réglementés de vente de l'électricité
que prévoit la réforme européenne merci
beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup monsieur le
député
Tavel je ne suis pas sûr que je je
puisse répondre à tous vos éléments
parce queedf n'est qu'un opérateur donc
deff ne fait pas les cadres de marché ne
fait pas pas les lois et cetera et
cetera donc nous les appliquons euh pour
ce qui est de vos questions il y a un
point sur lequel je voudrais être précis
quand
même vous dites 110 € du mgawh
eDF va pouvoir faire ses prix jusqu'à
110 € du
mgaw non eDF va avoir pour objectif de
faire des prix équilibrés qui qui
reflètent une économie de long terme
c'est bien l'engagement que nous avons
pris et ceci afin d'amener un volume
d'électricité élevé sur le marché
français qui permettent d'atterrir vers
le fameux 70 € en moyenne voilà notre
objectif c'est notre engagement bien sûr
je voudrais simplement rappeler que
aujourd'hui quand on ne parle que de la
part fourniture de l'électricité tout le
monde paye plus de 110 € du mgawh tout
le monde voilà donc quand on dit que
notre objectif c'est d'arriver à ce que
la part fourniture parce que quand vous
prenez tout évidemment ça amène à
beaucoup plus de 110 mais quand on dit
que la part fourniture notre objectif
c'est de converger en moyenne vers 70 on
parle bien d'un atterrissage des prix
que et que l'on parle
d'entreprise évidemment que l'on parle
de l'ensemble des clients enfin je je
voudrais dire un mot sur sur les les
questions de structure de marché encore
une fois ça n'est pas EDF qui fixe les
règles nous ce que nous souhaitons c'est
avoir une concurrence je pense que la
concurrence est bonne pour je l'avais
dit dès le mois de novembre 2022 devant
cette commission parce que ça nous aide
êre bon mais nous souhaitons une vraie
concurrence et nous souhaitons des
concurrents qui investissent dans les
moyens de production électrique aussi
sur notre territoire merci beaucoup je
vous propose de passer au groupe les
républicains et c'est Jérôme nu qui
porte la parole du
groupe merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président d'EDF
EDF est une entreprise à part une
entreprise qui a une place particulière
dans le cœur des Français et dans leur
quotidien on l'a vu il y a quelques mois
et l'hiver dernier quand EDF tous c'est
toute la France qui rhume nous allons
passer un hiver plus tranquille en terme
de production et nous ne pouvons que
nous en réjouir et féliciter
l'encadrement vous-même et tous les
personnels qui ont travaillé dur pour
revenir à des niveaux de production
rassurants nous sommes donc sereins sur
le court terme sur le long terme afin
d'investir dans le prolongement du parc
nucléaire actuel d'investir dans les
énergies renouvelables et d'investir
massivement dans les nouvelles centrales
donc pr SMR eDF va devoir dégager 60 à
70 milliards d'euros de capitaux la
situation de votre entreprise que l'État
et le gouvernement a délibérément
surendetté pour éviter une hausse trop
importante de l'électricité au cours des
derniers mois va-t-elle permettre de
dégager suffisamment de cash pour ces
investissements stratégique et essentiel
pour l'avenir de notre pays sur le moyen
terme nous devons être vigilant sur un
point sur lequel vous ne vous êtes pas
trop attarder vous avez parlé de
compétitivité pour les entreprises de
stabilité euh et d'investissement mais
vous n'avez pas beaucoup parlé du niveau
des prix que nos concitoyens paieront
demain après laarine leur électricité
quand on parle du nouvel accord européen
post arè avec une référence à 70 € du
mgaw il faut transcrire ou traduire en
terme de tarif pour le consommateur
final aujourd'hui les Français qui ont
gardé un abonnement classique de
particulier réglementé paye autour de 20
centimes d'eurau du
kilow une hausse déjà de 7 à 8 € du
kilow en par rapport à la période
précédente après aprèscise donc à 70 €
du mgaw quel sera approximativement ce
prix final 30 € 30 centimes d'euros du
du kilow 40 centimes 50 centimes il faut
être transparent sur ce point qui est un
sujet d'inquiétude pour nos concitoyens
que l'on encourage je rappelle à passer
au tout électrique le chauffage les
voitures mais Don les les finances
courantes sont aujourd'hui vous le savez
mis à mal par l'inflation merci de votre
réponse sur ce sujet qui est important à
mon avis pour nos concitoyens et pour
les Français merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup monsieur le
député merci pour vos encouragements
pour les équipes deedf je elles y sont
sensibles je le
sais vous avez parfaitement raison de
dire que la la stabilité des prix la
prévisibilité des prix est un élément
absolument déterminant pour nos
concitoyens évidemment il est au cœur
des préoccupations d' DF euh qui doit
continuer de travailler sur la
compétitivité de son propre parc et sur
sa performance et y compris sur ses
coûts pour être au rendez-vous des
meilleures conditions possibles pour nos
concitoyens aujourd'hui effectivement
nos concitoyens le tarif réglementé de
vente pour nos concitoyens est de 258 €
du mgawh donc 25 centimes d'euros du
kilow à peu près euh une fois que vous
intégrez la totalité des dimensions de
l'électricité et là-dedans vous avez
beaucoup de par paramètres dont la
fourniture n'est que un paramètre donc
le 70 ne se compare pas au 258 he c'est
clair il se compare plutôt à un horizon
qui est de 220 à à 120 à 130 aujourd'hui
dans la part fourniture du tarif
existant mais aujourd'hui nos
concitoyens ont été fortement protégés
par le contribuable sur l'année 2023
alors c'est également nos concitoyens
qui le paye comme contribuable mais il
ne le voi pas dans leur facture
d'électricité et donc la nécessité que
nous avons sur les deux années qui
viennent avant d'entrer dans le régime
futur qui commence par à partir de 2026
c'est de créer les conditions de cet
atterrissage dans lequel le contribuable
qui aujourd'hui finalement protège nos
concitoyens particuliers au travers du
bouclier va progressivement revenir à
d'autres priorités parce que c'est
naturel dans un dans une phase de
détente des prix et progressivement
c'est le nouveau régime qui va
s'installer avec un objectif qui est
celui qui a été annoncé par le
gouvernement et auquel naturellement EDF
souscrit totalement qui est de
stabiliser les prix pour nos concitoyens
voilà je sais pas vous dire exactement
quel sera le prix à ce moment-là parce
que il y a 2024 et 2025 sur lesquels il
n a pas échappé que les tarifs c'est pas
DF qui les fixe et donc sur 2024 le
gouvernement a été très clair en disant
que la hausse serait de 10 % maximum
voilà donc nous allons créer les
conditions d'un atterrissage des prix
dont nos concitoyens auront le bénéfice
aussi je ne suis pas à ce jour capable
de vous dire exactement à quel prix le
tarif sera en 2026 en tout cas il fera
l' d'un lissage ce qui permettra d'avoir
le même effet que ce que nous allons
chercher pour les entreprises grâce au
contrat de long terme pour faire en
sorte que cet atterrissage soit possible
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
au groupe démocrate et c'est Eric
Martino qui porte la parole de son
groupe merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Directeur vous
l'avez rappelé les prix de l'électricité
augmenté avec la guerre en Ukraine la
hausse des cours sur le les marchés de
l'énergie les réacteurs nucléaires ent
en attente de réparation et aussi par
manque de de salariés pour réaliser
certaines soudures le parc nucléaire a
fait l'objet de travaux d'ampleur en
2023 ce qui a permis d'éviter le
délestage euh électrique l'hiver dernier
et grâce aussi aux efforts de sobriété
des Français cet hiver il convient de
marquer cette et de de maintenir pardon
cette sobriété énergétique qui est bonne
pour le portefeuille comme pour la
planète et le marché européen
l'électricité a été réformé en 2023 en
tenant compte de la force de la France
et de son parc nucléaire je salue la
baisse des prix et le bouclier tarifaire
financé par l'État plusieurs milliards
chaque année depuis 2021 mais qui
prendra fin à la mi 2024 mais
aujourd'hui les particuliers comme les
entreprises s'interrogent sur les tarifs
de l'électricité
EDF a annoncé une hausse des tarifs
réglementés de l'électricité de l'ordre
de 10 % au maximum en
2024 mais certains contrats ont été
signés au plus haut mettant en danger
nos PME et artisans y compris certaines
collectivités certaines entreprises se
tourne vers des groupes électrogènes car
le fiel est moins cher que l'électricité
écologiquement ce n'est pas défendable
et nous ne pouvons pas encourager qu'en
est-il de la rénégociation de contrat
signés au plus haut car à ce jour les
tarifs de de l'électricité ont fortement
baissé depuis l'été 2022 comment
rassurer nos concitoyens je vous
remercie monsieur merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
monsieur le député
martinau et et merci de vos
encouragements également euh alors il
est clair que les conditions
d'atterrissage de sortie de crise sont
difficiles à trouver parce que euh
effectivement il y a des contrats qui
ont été bouclés au moment où les prix
étaient très élevés et face auxquel
EDF comme les autres fournisseurs se
sont engagés donc pour nous c'est une
dette également euh c'est difficile à
comprendre mais nous nous avons
évidemment des engagements qui
correspondent à ces contrats et donc
renégocier ces contrats c'est quelque
chose qui est impossible vu des Four des
des producteurs et des fournisseurs que
nous sommes
en revanche ce qui est clair c'est que
nous devons absolument travailler avec
l'ensemble de nos clients pour créer les
conditions de cet atterrissage vers le
fameux 70 € de MWh en moyenne au-delà de
l'horizon 2026 et pour cela nous sommes
d'ors et déjà en mesure et nous le
serons encore plus à partir du mois de
janvier de proposer des contrats de
moyen terme qui permettent de tirer long
et plus on tire long tout de suite plus
on permet notamment aux
PME que vous avez cité et qui sont
évidemment le cœur de notre Pr
occupation de de se rassurer très très
vite sur les conditions dans lesquelles
ils auront ou elles auront de
l'électricité à cet horizonl et d'éviter
que l'angoisse et le moment très
difficile qu'ils ont vécu en 2023 euh
puisse rester voilà donc c'est sur ces
conditionsl que nous nous engageons et
nous sommes au contact de nos clients et
nous allons le faire à très grande
échelle maintenant que cet accord est
conclu et qu'il nous donne de la
visibilité sur 26 et au-delà pour faire
en sorte que sur les horizons de temps
qui sont naturellement l'année 2020 24
elle est déjà conclue mais 25 26 27 28
et 29 à partir du 1er janvier nous
puissions proposer à nos clients et que
nos concurrents puissent proposer aussi
à leurs clients grâce à l'électricité
qu'ils achèteront sur le marché de gros
à ces horizons là et que nous nous
engageons à fournir des conditions qui
sont attractives et qui sont beaucoup
plus
compétitives merci beaucoup comme il
reste 20 secondes une
relance ce qui me dérange c'est juste
ces entreprises qui investissent dans
des groupes électrogènes et qui s'il y a
bien un tarif c'est vrai du qui a été
contractualisé il y a pas le volume et
donc en clair les entreprises préfèrent
utiliser du fuel que d'utiliser de
l'électricité et c'est là-dessus que je
pense qu'il il y a quelque chose à
revoir et j'espère que nos artisans même
certaines boulangeries moi je pense à
une de ma circonscription qui m'avait
encore appelé la semaine dernière
j'espère qu'elle arrivera à tenir
jusqu'en 2025 je vous
remercie merci alors très court euh
président allez-y non mais on est
évidemment n'hésitez pas à nous signaler
des situations d'entreprise et nous les
regardons toutes une par une
évidemment et puis voilà le but j'ai
bien conscience qu'il y a des situations
de crise le but c'est que nous puissions
sortir le plus vite possible et nous
serons évidemment au contact des
entreprises pour ça merci beaucoup pour
le groupe socialiste c'est Marie Noë
btistel qui porte la parole de son
groupe c'est à vous merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général j'aurais
évidemment beaucoup de questions mais le
temps est limité je me concentrerai sur
trois sujets tout d'abord l'enjeu de la
réforme du marché et de celle du
mécanisme de laaren doit évidemment être
de garantir la protection des ménages de
la volatilité des prix de garantir la
compétitivité de nos entreprises tout en
assurant une capacité d'investissement
suffisante à EDF c'est une équation pas
simple à résoudre vous y avez longuement
travaillé il est proposé aujourd'hui des
dispositifs de CFD des PIP pa entre
producteur et consommateurs et un prix
fixé environ 70 € avec une
redistribution progressive à partir de
78 € alors trois questions comment
assurer la protection des
consommateurs dans la durée et également
en cas de crise tel qu'on l'a connu
alors même que vous avez répondu à
l'instant à notre collègue nu que vous
n'étiez pas en capacité de connaître le
prix de 2026 donc comment comment
s'assurer de la stabilité pour les
consommateurs deuxème question comment
sera organisée la redistribution aux
consommateurs on a assez peu d'éléments
là-dessus est-ce que ce serait par
exemple sur un mécanisme de CSPE
flottante euh est-ce que cet accord pour
ma 3è question euh longuement travaillé
permettra de financer un programme à 6
pr et le grand carénage à combien à ce
stade évaluez-vous cet investissement et
avec quel portage et évidemment une
dernière question sur l'avenir des
concessions hydroélectriques et la
réforme du régime en cours à savoir le
passage du régime concessif au régime
d'autorisation est-ce que à ce stade des
discussions vous êtes assuré de la
solidité juridique de ce projet et dans
le cas de l'adoption de cette réforme
quel type d'investissement cela vous
permettrait d'engager au-delà évidemment
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de le pointer
à nouveau des augmentations de puissance
dont on attend toujours les
autorisations plus de 3 ans après la loi
qui le permettez je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup madame la
députée btistel euh bon sur la
protection du consommateur je comme j'ai
peu de temps je vais être assez rapide
le le ce que je ne connais pas c'est le
tarif réglementé de vente 2026 parce que
par définition il répond à un mécanisme
de fixation qui échappe à EDF et qui
Infiné sera fait par la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie mais sur les les
horizons de prix de l'électricité
notamment sur le marché de gros à cet
horizon nous connaissons les prix
puisqu'ils sont formés tous les jours
sur les marchés de gros et c'est là que
nous voyons cet atterrissage et le
dégonflement rapide de ces prix
notamment depuis l'annonce de l'accord
du gouvernement puisque nous avons perdu
15 % depuis l'annonce de l'accord avec
le gouvernement ce qui prouve que quand
on amène du volume d'électricité sur ces
marchés on a une détente des prix qui
est réelle euh sur le fonctionnement du
mécanisme de redistribution le
gouvernement le fixera de façon précise
dans le cadre de la loi que vous aurez à
examiner mais le principe c'est que la
redistribution descend directement dans
la facture du client et de façon
déterministe c'estàdire que le CLIENT
sait effectivement ce sur quoi il peut
compter en terme de redistribution pour
son pied de facture que ce soit un
client particulier ou entreprise c'est
bien ça l'objectif les modalités sont en
cours de fixation sur les
investissements naturellement il nous
reste encore beaucoup de travail pour
faire euh pour élaborer euh le programme
des 6 pr et pour le monter en cadence
Industri industriel mais ce qui est
clair c'est que l'objet de cet accord
c'est de faire en sorte que EDF puisse
avoir une espérance de revenus faut être
performant pour que les revenus soient
au rendez-vous donc il faut que la
production soit aux alentours de 360 TWh
et avec un objectif de monter à 400 avec
Flamanville sur la base d'augmentation
de puissance également que nous irons
chercher sur le parc existant mais il
faut évidemment que ceci combiné avec
notre espérance de revenus autour de 70
€ en moyenne de 2022 sur les années qui
viennent nous aurons la capacité de
financer le grand carénage et une côte
partart déterminante du programme des
6op sur l'hydro parce que je peux pas ne
pas parler de l'hydro à Madame batistel
évidemment sur l'hydro nous avons
énormément de travail fait et nous avons
une confiance très forte dans la
solidité du régime juridique que nous
avons proposé naturellement il faut
maintenant que les instances
gouvernementales et le Parlement examine
in ce sujet dans les temps euh sur les
investissements évidemment ça commence
par les augmentations de puissance et
par les par du stockage nous avons
besoin d'équilibrer le système
électrique qui est de plus en plus
intermittent le parc nucléaire peut le
faire en partie mais le mieux pour le
parc nucléaire c'est de fonctionner en
permanence et donc les steps par exemple
qui peuvent être faits sur les barrages
existants sont le type d'investissement
que nous allons chercher en priorité sur
la base du régime d'autorisation merci
beaucoup je propose de passer au groupe
horizon et c'est Xavier Albertini qui
porte la parole du groupe monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président
Directeur Général mes chers collègues
merci monsieur le Président pour vos
premières explications et informations
vous vous évoquez un cercle virtueux à
la fois à moyen terme et à et à long
terme et vous vous nous expliquez la
nécessité de tirer le commerce vers le
long terme je peux que me réjouir
d'avoir cette vision qui consiste à voir
loin pour faire bien ça me paraît
quelque chose d'assez intéressant en
revanche vous offrez vous vous évoquez
la notion de l'offre off en particulier
qui doit être sécurisé pour à la fois
répondre aux intérêts des particuliers
et des des entreprises en
électrointensive je voudrais faire un un
pas de côté si vous me le permettez pour
que vous puissiez nous nous nous
indiquer euh techniquement comment vous
voyez euh non pas le 24 29 mais plutôt
un peu après c'est-à-dire la la
sécurisation de la production
d'électricité avec la construction des
six nouveaux op et puis ensuite très
certainement le ceux qui devront suivre
dans la mesure où certains esprits
chagrin s'inquiètent déjà de la capacité
de cadencement de cette de ces entités
et en particulier la question qui qui me
qui me vient ce matin en vous écoutant
c'est la question du respect du
cadancement avec votre capacité de
sécuriser à la fois les filières
matérielles mais aussi humaines dans le
cadre de de ces fameuses constructions
est-il possible monsieur le Président
que vous puissiez nous rassurer ce matin
et nous dire comment vous entendez à
moyen terme cette fois-ci
sécuriser cette la livraison de ces
superstructures ce qui en quelque sorte
sécurisera l'offre et ainsi permettra
d'assurer à la fois au particulierers et
aux entreprises une vision que nous
espérons tous avec une vision à long
terme je vous remercie merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
monsieur le député Albertini vous mettez
le doigt je pense sur un sujet qui est
absolument fondamental sur la réussite
de notre programme électrique national
c'est pas juste nucléaire je pense c'est
vraiment la réussite de notre programme
électrique national qui est à la clé du
sujet que vous avez cité qui est le
cadencement je pense c'est le plus grand
défi industriel de DF de la décennie qui
vient que d'être capable de construire à
nouveau à l'échelle industrielle ça
suppose une refonte totale fondamental
de la façon dont nous prenons les
projets notamment dans le nucléaire
principalement dans le nucléaire pour
une raison assez simple qui est que
depuis 25 ans notre pays n'a pas
construit à l'échelle nous avons fait un
réacteur en France en 25 ans et comme
dans toute industrie quand on fait peu
on perd l'habitude de faire vite et donc
nous devons impérativement si si nous
sommes si nous voulons être crédiible
sur la décarbonation sur la capacité
d'avoir un système électrique équilibré
entre des ressources renouvelables qui
doivent également monter en cadence et
des mais qui restent intermittente et
des ressources commandabl et décarbonés
nous devons monter en cadence sur la
production pour cela nous sommes en
train de changer profondément
l'organisation de DF euh c'est en phase
de consultation avec les partenaires
sociaux euh pour faire en sorte que le
l'étape de construction d'intégration de
nos nouveaux réacteurs puissent être
mené en cadence industrielle c'est un
changement très profond et qui
évidemment embarque la totalité de notre
filière industrielle qui je dois dire
répond présent à cet effort et ça
suppose vraiment de revoir les détails
c'est un travail de détail les détails
de comment nous amenons les chantiers à
être profilés comment nous amenons les
objets sur les chantiers comment nous
mettons les les compétences à
disposition des différents chantiers au
bon moment pour faire en sorte que nous
ne perdions pas de temps dans la phase
d'intégration ce qui est l'élément le
plus
déterminant de pour pour la réussite de
notre programme donc nous avons du
travail devant nous pour y arriver euh à
ce jour je ne peux pas vous dire que
nous sommes prêts euh parce que je pense
qu'il y a énormément de travail pour
être prêt
euh ce qui nous encourage tous chez EDF
c'est que nos anciens y sont
arrivés ils sont arrivés avec moins de
contrainte mais aussi moins d'outils
donc si nos anciens sont arrivés à
raccorder quatre réacteurs par an dans
notre pays au pic de la production du
parc nucléaire d'aujourd'hui normalement
nous devrions être capable d'aller vers
un réacteur par an en France et deux
réacteurs par an en Europe grosso modo
et donc c'est bien vers cet horizon là
de capacité industrielle qui n faut
tendre et ça nécessite un travail
fondamental qui est engagé merci
beaucoup pour le groupe écologiste c'est
Delphine bateau qui porte la parole de
son groupe c'est à
vous merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Directeur Général
euh un sentiment de perplexité partagé
avec de nombreux collègues parce que la
la réforme européenne dont on parle
apparaît à la fois très tardive alors
que le mal a été fait et très
insuffisante sur le fond euh parce que
alors que le choc énergétique euh de
2021-2022 aurait dû conduire à un
tournant historique de remise à plat on
reste fondamentalement dans une logique
d'amendement du marché européen de
l'électricité et non euh d'une refonte
complète et on reste dans un cadre euh
qui considère que la main invisible du
marché certes régulée euh peut bien
s'occuper de l' énergie et c'est faire
un pari pour l'avenir qui me paraît
extrêmement risqué
euh des questions assez assez limité euh
puisque de toute façon le Parlement aura
à débattre de ce sujet la première c'est
sur le fait que je lis que le contrat
pour différence s'agissant de la France
et de DF euh devra être soumis à la
question de sa compatibilité au régime
des aides d'État et qu'il y aurait donc
absolument aucune certitude sur le cadre
applicable euh par ailleurs les
dispositions sont pas complètement
finalisées
aujourd'hui ensuite
2027-2028 c'est loin alors que la hausse
des prix de l'électricité pour les
ménages et pour les entreprises c'est
tout de suite pour en 2022 pour les
ménages ça a été il me semble près de
400 € euh en en
moyenne donc bon vous avez renvoyé au
gouvernement cette question question
mais comprenez qu'elle est absolument
centrale et enfin le tarif de de 70
€ c'est les 60 € de la creux plus 10 €
de nouveau
nucléaire dans la mesure où le le Pr de
flamandville ne ne fonctionne toujours
pas et où nous ne sommes toujours pas
assurés de son coût final pour la
nation qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
nous dire de de ce mode de calcul des 10
€ au regard de de l'expérience
de LEPR de flamandville en matière de
dérapage total des coûts pour la nation
et le
contribuable merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup madame la
députée je ve pas commenter sur la
réforme européenne moi je suis un
observateur de depuis de longues date de
de
l'électricité je pense que il y a un pas
très significatif qui est fait dans un
cadre de marché dans un cadre de marché
pour compléter un marché qui était trop
court terme et et ça c'est un pas très
significatif qui était attendu c'est
tout à fait clair depuis longtemps par
tous les opérateurs et et c'est un pas
qui va dans la bonne direction le
deuxième élément qui est clé c'est que
il y a un consensus européen sur le fait
que la décarbonation est l'objectif
collectif et que le choix des
technologies qui permettent la
décarbonation relève des choix nationaux
et donc c'est une forme d'agnosticité
sur euh sur les conditions et enfin il y
a une boîte à outils euh qui est assez
ouverte sur quels sont les instruments
financiers quels sont les instruments
juridiques qui peuvent être laissés à la
disposition des états pour financer leur
programme électrique voilà les éléments
clé de cet accord qui me paraisse euh
suffisamment historique pour être
souligné euh la l'accord que nous avons
conclu avec le gouvernement ne nécessite
pas la mobilisation d'outils qui nous
amèneraiit à une négociation
communautaire sur sur la régulation de
l'électricité nous utilisons des
instruments qui sont parfaitement
compatibles avec le cadre européen tel
qu'il est défini et qui utilise
finalement la boîte à outil existante
sans avoir à négocier quoi que ce soit
qui relève d'une aide d'État àedf il y a
absolument rien qui nécessite d'aller
vers une négociation communautaire nous
aurons
besoin non on a on n pas mobilisé dans
la boîte à outil on n'a pas mobilisé
d'outil qui nécessit de faire ça le
moment venu sur le nouveau nucléaire
naturellement comme EDF ne pourra pas
porter la totalité du financement du
nouveau nucléaire comme aucun opérateur
en Europe quelle que soit la technologie
ne porte la totalité des risques
associés à un investissement aujourd'hui
tous les investissements dans
l'électricité bénéficient d'une forme de
soutien public soit sous forme de
garantie soit sous forme de CFD
EDF n'échappera pas à la règle pour le
nouveau nucléaire là nous aurons une
discussion de type aide d'État mais
c'est pour le nouveau nucléaire c'est
pour le nouveau nucléaire et ça nous n'y
sommes pas encore puisque que nous
devons d'abord monter l'ensemble du
programme voilà enfin j'ai bien pris
votre point sur le fait que c'est tout
de suite nous nous y travaillons le plus
possible dans le cadre des règles qui
s'imposent à nous et sur 24 et 25 nous
sommes toujours dans le cadre de l'arène
merci beaucoup nous passons au groupe
gdrs c'est Sébastien Jumel qui porte la
parole de son
groupe monsieur le Président Directeur
Général lorsqu'elle est venue en
audition agas panier runch nous a dit
dans toutes les langues la reine est
morte vive le Roi marché et et c'est et
c'est évidemment la malformation
cogénitale qui et l'environnement qu'on
vous impose d'une certaine manière dans
vos responsabilité importante moi je le
dis je ne me trompe pas de responsable
en la matière il appartient aux
politiques à l'échelle nationale comme à
l'échelle
européenne de sortir l'énergie de sa
logique de marché moi je suis ringar je
ne suis pas victime de la mode comme
disait MC solar je pense que l'énergie
bien de première nécessité bien commun
euh nécessite euh d'en prendre soin pour
les précaires énergétiques pour la
souveraineté pour l'indépendance pour la
compétitivité de nos industrie tel n'est
pas le choix aujourd'hui il nous
appartiendra une fois au responsabilité
de revenir sur cette malformation
congénitale dans cette logique de marché
vous
avez l'impérieuse nécessité de procéder
à la relance de la filière nucléaire
d'autant que les objectifs
d'électrification des usages vont devoir
faire passer la production électrique à
un
niveau évidemment sans commune mesure 55
% de la consommation d'énergie devra
être à l'horizon 2050 d'origine
électrique alors il y a le
prix conclu avec l'État il y a les
différents mécanismes que vous nous avez
présentés mais il y a l'obligation de
d'injecter 25 milliards d'euros par an
dans la relance comment allez-vous
financer ces premiers investissements
pour les 6 pr et les prochains parce que
l'exemplarité sociale environnementale
technologique industrielle de cette
relance passe quand même par ses
capacités d'investissement
qu'attendez-vous du gouvernement pour
cela y y a-t-il des contreparties exigés
par Bruxelles pour ça c'est évidemment
une question qui nous est posée deuxème
question pour ne pas être trop long
pendant 15 ans les concurrents de DF les
marchands de savonnette de soleil ont
bénéficié d'avantage exorbitant et même
de financement gras euh réservé par le
mécanisme de laaren aujourd'hui ils se
plaignent auprès de l'exécutif de la fin
de l'obben sans avoir d'ailleurs pu
préparer la fin de cet auben
euh comment EDF s'organise dans ces
nouvelles offres de marché et quelle
analyse faites-vous de cette nouvelle
donne concurrentielle des marchés post
2025 vis-à-vis des intermittents du
spectacle euh comme je les appelle voilà
deux questions que j'ai posé alors
ensuite la ministre na pas complètement
rassurer sur le mécanisme prévu pour
garantir des prix stabilisés régulés
pour nos consommateurs première ligne
pouvez-vous revenir là-dessus merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup monsieur le député jumelle
euh je je je ne sais pas si je
reprendrai à mon compte votre expression
sur sur l'arène est morte mais et je je
suis certain que je vous convaincrai pas
sur sur un mécanisme de marché ça c'est
clair ce que je voudrais dire simplement
mais vraiment très simplement c'est que
la ren avait réussi à accumuler les
inconvénients du marché et de la
régulation ce que j'espère c'est que le
nouveau dispositif cumulera les
avantages de ces deux mondes et c'est
bien comme ça qu'on a essayé de le
concevoir donc c'est un pivot assez
important et je pense que la preuve a
été faite au fil des années que nous
avions les défauts des deux systèmes
dans le cadre de l'arène il nous fallait
en sortir
euh sur comment euh financer les
investissements la première condition
pour financer les investissements
c'était d'être de capable de dégager des
revenus pour être capable d'autofinancer
sans euh sans surendetter EDF EDF est
déjà significativement endetté eDF n'a
pas la capacité de se surendetter bien
sûr euh euh donc la première condition
c'était de dégager des revenus l'accord
que nous avons concl nous permet un
horizon de revenus naturellement il faut
les réaliser pour ça il nous faut monter
notre production et être capable d'être
performant c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure comme la condition qui
responsabilise
EDF la deuxième condition c'est
qu'évidemment comme tout investisseur
dans la production électrique dans toute
l'Europe aujourd'hui nous allons devoir
demander des conditions de soutien des
pouvoirs publics sur le programme des
6ep nous pouvions pas le faire de façon
très opérationnelle tant que nous ne
savions pas quel était la capacité de
génération de revenus de l'entreprise et
donc sa propre capacité
d'autofinancement depuis quelques
semaines nous avons une meilleure
visibilité là-dessus donc nous sommes en
situation maintenant de travailler
d'arrachepied avec les administrations
et avec le gouvernement pour définir le
plan de financement de ces 6 pr en
faisant appel à des outils qui sont
classiques
connus ce que nous allons faire dans les
mois qui viennent merci je répond si je
peux me permettre j'étais plus court sur
sur la question de la concurrence
évidemment nous nous souhaitons de la
concurrence et nous souhaitons une
concurrence saine une concurrence saine
c'est une concurrence qui est
responsable en terme de production et de
consommation nous fournirons nos
concurrents en terme d'électricité ça
fait partie des engagements que nous
prenons naturellement et nous les
fournirons dans des conditions qui leur
assure une transparence une équité pour
faire en sorte que l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens quel que soi leur
fournisseurs puisse avoir au même accès
aux mêmes conditions de
compétitivité merci beaucoup pour le
groupeat je propose d'écouter monsieur
Benjamin saintuile qui porte la parole
de son
groupe merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Directeur Général
l'avantage de passer le 10e c'est que
vous avez traité une partie des sujets
ou qu'en tout cas les collègues les ont
évoqué moi je veux donc ne pas passer
trop de temps sur les les le prix des
usagers parce qu'on a bien compris que
pour l'instant nous sommes sous le
régime de laarine pour les 2 ans qui
viennent et que derrière on ne sait pas
dire où on atterrit ça veut dire qu'on
sortira d'ici ce n'est pas un reproche
qui vous est fait à vous mais enfin
sortira d'ici sans être tout à fait
rassuré sur ce que pont les
consommateurs demain et c'est donc
difficile de dire aux gens que nous
voyons tous les jours chez nous que il
faut se réjouir de cet accord parce que
finalement il s'agit aujourd'hui de
considérer que la visibilité qui est
donné à travers cet accord sera un gage
a priori de stabilisation on a entendu
l'argumentaire il est construit et tout
à fait intelligible il faudra vérifier
la dans la réalité opérationnelle que on
s'y retrouve très honnêtement en sortant
d'ici j'ai pas un argument solide
sérieux pour dire ça va d'aller brav
gens ça va être stable c'est un peu
compliqué donc je vais pas passer trop
de temps là-dessus on va passer un peu
plus de temps sur la question du mur
d'investissement qui est devant nous
vous l'avez évoqué à l'instant suite à
la question de Monsieur
Jumel vous dites il faudra qu'on soit
bon bon commerçant bon industriel et bon
investisseur pour pouvoir faire face à
ce mur d'investissement maintenant vous
avez cet accord venez de le dire à
l'instant ma question elle est donc
relativement simple euh pour réussir le
grand carénage et le gros les gros
investissements pr qui sont devant nous
il faut combien de votre point de vue
vous avez une une fixation d'objectif à
à 400 TWh avec flamandville c'est pour
quand et et du coup de manière plus
globale c'est quoi la capacité de DF à
injecter là-dedans qu'est-ce qui va
manquer de votre point de vue en théorie
sur le plan de financement si je suis
bête et méchant quelle est la capacité
de DF à faire faire avec cette nouvelle
perspective si vous êtes bons élèves
bons commerçants bons industriels c'est
quoi votre capacité maximum la code part
maximum que vous êtes en capacité de
soutenir et les premiers les premières
discussions les premiers tour de table
il font atterrir sur quel type de plan
de financement avec qui et surtout à
quelle hauteur parce que je me mets à la
place de ceux qui sont toujours un peu
dubitatifes sur le prix de sortie qui
est l'exemple de Flamanville pour
essayer de fixer un un un coûp
d'objectif d'investissement global
est-ce que vous êtes plutôt assuré ou
pas et puis vous avez évoqué lors de vos
propos la la nécessité de passer à une
cadence industrielle qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire en terme RH chez vous en terme
de réorganisation en terme de compéten
dans la boutique aujourd'hui et des
perspectives de recrutement et de et de
construction d'un bloc RH solide pour
faire face à ce mur d'investissement
bref voilà en quelques secondes ce qu'on
pouvait évoquer pour éviter d'être
redondant quelques secondes 3 minutes et
monsieur le Président votre réponse
merci beaucoup monsieur le député euh
bon tous les sujets que vous avez évoqué
sont vitaux et je suis pas sûr de
pouvoir les les synthétiser en 2 minutes
mais je vais faire de mon mieux
euh les 400 terw notre objectif c'est de
les atteindre en 2030 sur la base d'une
amélioration continue de la production
et du productible nucléaire qui inclut
évidemment Flamanville mais qui inclut
également l'augmentation de puissance du
parc existant euh c'est un objectif
exigeant hein le parc n'a jamais produit
durablement beaucoup plus de 400 TWh et
évidemment entre-temps il aura pris deux
ou trois décennies donc c'est un
objectif exigeant mais nous le
prenons notre capacité de financement ce
que nous devons financer c'est de
l'ordre de 25 milliards d'euros
d'investissement par an et donc sans se
surendetter ça suppose évidemment que
nous dégagions des résultats qui sont
supérieurs significativement à ça et
donc voilà quand nous annoncerons les
résultats de DF année après année et que
ces résultats commenceront par un 3 euh
il faudra pas qu'on qu'on se dise
EDF gagne trop d'argent non c'est juste
ce qu'il nous faut pour ne pas nous
surendetter pour faire face aux
investissements auxquels nous sommes
appelé dans ces investissements il y a
pas que le nucléaire il y a évidemment
on commence par le réseau le réseau de
distribution il a besoin de l'ordre de 5
milliards d'euros d'investissement par
an le Nucléa existant le grand carénage
représente lui aussi de l'ordre de 5
milliards d'euros d'investissement par
an donc sans avoir commencé à construire
quelque chose de neuf on est déjà à 10
milliards d'euros d'investissement par
an et ensuite si je rajoute le nouveau
nucléaire évidemment je dépasse assez
vite les 20 milliards d'euros par an
dans les années qui viennent donc voilà
c'est c'est c'est à cela que nous sommes
appelés si nous tenons nos objectifs
opérationnels c'est soutenable mais ça
nécessite aussi plus d'ailleurs pour des
raisons de disponibilité de du monde
financier à à accepter un volume de
dettes important sur EDF que pour des
raisons de soutenabilité économique euh
ça nécessite évidemment de répondre à un
défaut de marché finalement de
profondeur des marchés financiers pour
soutenir l'ensemble de ces
investissements à la fois sur ce pointl
que nous allons travailler sur le
dispositif dont nous avons besoin avec
le gouvernement merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président je vais donc passer aux
questions individuelles vous connaissez
le principe je prends toutes les
questions individuelles à ce stade j'ai
noté monsieur Stéphane traver Monsieur
Lionel Tivoli Laurent Alexandre Francis
Dubois Thierry Benoît max mathasin René
Pilato Jean-Pierre viget Maxime lénet
Jean-Luc Bourgeot Mathias Tavel si j'ai
fait des oublis lever la main et nous
commençons tout de suite avec Stéphane
traver c'est à vous et bien merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de de DF eDF prévoit la
construction de nouvelles piscines de
stockage et d'entreposage sous eau de de
combustible sur le site de de la Hague
ce centre est bien évidemment nécessaire
et se situe sur la partie ouest du site
occupé aujourd'hui par Orano euh ce
projet il s'inscrit dans une logique de
cohérence industrielle et le combustible
fera l'objet d'un d'un traitement
ultérieur d'ailleurs 2500 tonnes de
combustiblees sont déjà présents sur le
site de La Hague ce qui avec ce nouveau
site d'entreposage évitera de multiples
de multiples transports où est-ce que
nous en sommes aujourd'hui de la
concertation et le calendrier de de
départ sur la construction de ce de ce
nouveau site d'entreposage sera-t-il
tenu merci merci beaucoup Monsieur
Lionel
Tivoli je prends le relais madame engr
monsieur le Président merci chers
collègues Monsieur Raymond il y a
quelques semaines après d'apres
discussions avec les institutions
européennes sur l'apréarè puis avec vous
sur le tarif à appliquer le gouvernement
nous annoncé avoir accouché d'un petit
nouveau les contrats d'écart
compensatoirees bidirectionnel à un prix
fixé autour de 70 € mais sans davantage
de précision j'aimerais que vous nous
éclairiez sur les modalités exactes de
cette redistribution par exemple on sait
déjà que pour une électricité comprise
entre 80 et 110 € le M le MWh l'état
vous concède 50 % de l'excédent réalisé
et au-delà seulement 10 % le reste étant
redistribué au consommateurs l'on ne
sait pas en revanche si la réciprocité
existe est-ce qu'il est par exemple
envisagé que l'État ne rembourse à EDF
que 50 % de la différence du prix
constaté lorsque le coût de
l'électricité s'élève à 60 €. afin de
faire bénéficier conjoncturellement les
Français d'un prix qui serait le plus
proche possible des coûts de production
bien sûr sans obérer vos capacités
d'investissement sur la
durée ser alors il est aussi on a pu
aussi constater que la redistribution ne
s'effectuerait qu'annuellement sur la
base des évolutions
est le cas cela me semble profondément
injuste pour le consommateur merci
beaucoup monsieur Laura
Alexandre monsieur le Président il y a
un peu plus d'un an à l'occasion de
l'audition qui précédait votre
nomination à la tête de DF vous aviez
refusé de répondre à la question que
vous posez notamment mon collègue
Mathias Tavel quant à votre rémunération
que vous disiez ne pas connaître or
parce que nous sommes très attachés au
droit du travail il nous semble que
connaître sa fiche de paix est un
préalable qui n'est pas de trop pour t
salariés j'espère donc que depuis cette
audition on vous a transmis cette
information et par conséquent je réitère
la question demeurer sans réponse il un
an êtes-vous en mesure de nous indiquer
l'ensemble des rémunérations fixes et
variables que vous percevez au titre de
votre fonction de PDG de DF en effet
EDF étant depuis maintenant près de 80
ans un de nos plus grands flurons
publics dont vous avez de plus pris la
tête à moment charnière il me semble
opportun que votre rémunération soit
connue de la représentation nationale et
encore plus de nos concitoyens je vous
remercie pour votre réponse merci
beaucoup Monsieur Francis
Dubois merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur Général la
commission d'enquête sur la perte de
souveraineté énergétique à laquelle j'ai
participé et présidé par mon collègue l
Raphaël schenberger a confirmé que
l'hydroélectricité française était dans
l'impasse après 20 ans d'immobilisme de
l'État français aujourd'hui l'ensemble
des opérateurs français dont EDF opère
sous le régime des concessions non
renouvelées si bien que plus qu'aucun
investissement n'est possible pourtant
ce secteur représente 20 % de la
puissance hydro électrique totale
française et la qui totalité du stockage
électrique ce qui en fait la deuxème
source de production derrière le
nucléaire pour sortir de cet impasse et
que nos barrages parfaitement maîtrisés
par vos équipes à 80 % soi ainsi
protégés deux solutions sont
envisageables la casi régie ou le régime
d'autorisation l'été dernier devant
cette commission vous souteniez que pour
permettre la reprise des investissements
sur les sites hydroélectriques le
basculement des régimes des concessions
et régime d'autorisation était
souhaitaable quel sont les intérêts de
privilégier ce régime d'autorisation
quel est l'état d'avancement de votre
discussion avec le Gouvernement sur ce
point quelles sont les perspectives et
les capacité d'EDF pour relancer les
investissements et notamment les steps
sur la valid d'ordogne en corz et sous
quel calendrierciou merci Monsieur
Charles
rodouell oui monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin pour
répondre à nos questions vous nous avez
détailler les accords entre l'État et
EDF pour couvrir sur le moyen sur le
long terme les les factures des grands
industriels électrointensifs pouvez-vous
nous détailler les pistes de travail que
votre équipe et vous avez mené pour
couvrir également sur le moyen sur le
long terme les petites et moyennes
entreprises et les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire dans le cadre de tel
contrats je vous remercie merci beaucoup
Monsieur Thierry Benoît merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président de DF
je voudrais vous interroger sur un une
question très pratique qui concerne nos
concitoyens qui réalise des travaux
d'isolation des travaux de
d'installation d'équipement de chauffage
et qui par ces travaux sont éligibles au
primes énergie dans le cadre du
dispositif des certificats d'économie
d'énergie nous sommes régulièrement
sollicité dans nos permanences
parlementaires par des concitoyens qui
sont dans l'attente de prime énergie
versé par
EDF d'un montant de 2000 ça peut aller
parfois jusqu'à 5000 € et il il y a de
vraies difficultés en terme de
complexité et en terme de délai de
versement et pour un particulier qui
s'engage dans des travaux de rénovation
lorsqu'il est éligible à ce type de
dispositif et bien 2000 3000 ou 5000 €
de d'aide c'est quelque chose de
précieux et donc je vous interpelle pour
savoir Monsieur le Président desdf
quelle mesures vous comptez mettre en
œuvre pour fluidifier simplifier et
accélérer le versement de ces primes
merci merci beaucoup monsieur max
matizin
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues monsieur le
Président les les collectivités
département Territoire d'autrem sont
classé en zone non inter
connecté il y a quelques mois lors de
l'examen de la Loi sur les
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables il a été question bien sûr
de de mettre fin autant que que possible
de remplacer par des énergies
renouvelables l'énergie fossile
c'est-à-dire le diesel le charbon et le
file comment EDF compte s'impliquer pour
que par exemple nous passions de 65 %
euh d'énergie fossile pour ce qui est de
la production d'électricité en
Guadeloupe à euh euh à ce que à ce que
nous pourrions appeler euh l'ég
d'énergie renouvelable et par ailleurs
que pensez-vous de du développement des
fermes par exemple photo photo agrivolta
présenté par bien des opérateurs
aujourd'hui sur les territoires merci
beaucoup monsieur Sébastien Jumel pour
une
relance Je suis chargé par mon président
de groupe André chassen de vous poser
une question sur le projet de barrage de
loyette qui est qui est porté par la
compagnie nationale du rô mais il est
intéressé pour savoir quelle est
l'opinion de DF sur ce projet et surtout
quelle est la compatibilité de ce projet
avec la construction prévue de le PR2 à
buget il y a-t-il des des des
articulations possibles des
contradictions envisagé voilà la la
question de du président chassen la
deuxième qui est la
mienne comme député de de Diab panli
quand il y a des investissements massifs
comme ceux que connaît la Normandie vous
sembleriez est-ce que ça vous semble
pertinent d'envisager des
contreparties euh d'aménagement du
territoire en matière d'électrification
des usages quand l'effort d'une région
en matière de production énergétique est
à ce niveau est-ce que c'est déconnant
d'envisager l'électrification des lignes
SNCF par exemple merci merci beaucoup
Monsieur René
Pilato merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Directeur Général
de DF monsieur raaymond vous annoncez un
besoin d'investissement de 25 milliards
combien sont prévus pour le nucléaire
par rapport aux énergies renouvelables
deuxièmement l'association ngawat pointe
un risque de mur électrique d'ici à
2030-235 la prévision pour les PR c'est
au mieux 2037 la question est simple
dans le cadre de la souveraineté de la
France au niveau énergétique que
prévoyez-vous pour sécuriser
l'approvisionnement de notre pays si les
PR ne sont pas prêts à temps merci merci
Monsieur Jean-Pierre Vigier
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président Directeur Général
l'hydroélectricité fait partie des
potentiels et vous le savez qui ne sont
pas complètement exploités dans notre
pays son développement est nécessaire à
l'heure où l'ensemble des modes de
production renouvelables doivent être
mobilisés pour atteindre les objectifs
nationaux et européens en matière
d'énergie renouvelable et vous le savez
c'est aussi un outil d'aménagement du
territoire et de développement
d'économie locale en effet les
installations hydroélectrique génère des
recettes fiscales et des emplois
induisant un ancrage local des
populations
notamment en montagne la majorité du
potentiel de développement de la filière
concerne des projets de petite
hydroélectricité dont la production est
un réel atout aussi comment l'entreprise
EDF compte-elle accompagner cette
filière tout en respectant bien sûr la
continuité écologique des cours d'eau je
vous remercie merci Monsieur
hervpino Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de DF une question
poil à gratter la présidente de la creux
annoncé en septembre dernier une hausse
des tarifs réglementés l'électricité de
l'ordre de 10 à 20 % début 2024 une
hausse qui vient s'ajouter au Hauses
vertigineuse des années
2022-2023 c'est la hausse infinie du
prix de l'électricité pour le
consommateur c'est l'échec de la
renégociation du marché européen de
l'électricité c'est une perte de
compétitivité pour l'économie française
au profit de l'Allemagne qui a encore
une fois tiré son épingle du jeu
monsieur le Président vous avez mis sur
la table du gouvernement votre démission
si l'état venait à ré le prix de
l'électricité à la baisse pour le
consommateur vous apparaissez donc
davantage comme une composante du
problème qu'une part de la solution
quels sont vos arguments pour contredire
cette
impression merci Monsieur Maxime
Lenet merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Raymond bonjour deux questions
la première sur le SMR newward qui avec
tout le respect que j'ai évidemment pour
les équipe de DF qui qui travaille sur
ces projets constitue à mon sens plutôt
un miroir aux alouettes mais est-ce que
vous avez est-ce que vous pouvez nous
renseigner sur le calendrier de de
développement de ce de ce petit réacteur
modulaire c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment espérer euh remplacer d'autres
d'autres formes d'énergie par ce par ce
ce type de production nucléaire et
est-ce que vous confirmez que c'est pour
mettre dans des grands sites industriels
c'est-à-dire des sites CVO et est-ce que
vous avez un endroit déjà privilégié
pour pour l'installer 2è question c'est
sur les PR2 visiblement monsieur Macron
a déjà décidé de faire les h de plus que
que les six qui sont engagés est-ce que
vous vous sentez prêt à relever le défi
où est-ce qu'on les mettrait est-ce
qu'on les mettrait près des fleuves
comme celui du budget pour lequel on va
être obligé de construire un nouveau
barrage à Saint-Romain de jalonas si
j'ai bien compris voilà merci pour vos
réponses merci nous avons monsieur
Jean-Luc Borgeot excusez-moi
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général comme l'a
fait mon collègue Kie benoî je voudrais
aborder avec vous les dysfonctionnements
qui peuvent arriver dans les demandes de
d'énergie de DF pour l'installation de
pompe à chaleur sur ma circonscription
j'ai un dossier qui n'est toujours pas
soldé malgré toutes les preuves d'une
procédure bien respecté vous serait-il
possible de demander à vos équipes
d'avoir un regard bienveillant sur ces
dossierers bien souvent ces personnes
ont des revenus très faibles merci à
vous merci beaucoup monsieur
Tangui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Raymond première chose il y a
aucun lien entre le fait d'échanger de
l'électricité avec nos voisins et le
fait que règle du marché électricité
soit libéralisé et vous le savez près
bien très bien donc ne prenez pas la
représentation nationale pour des
imbéciles même si la tentation est
grande contte tenu des décisions passées
qui ont été prises sur l'électricité ma
question c'est dans la le dernier
rapport de la Cour des comptes il y a
sur le prix de l'électricité il y a bien
une dérive des coûts puisqu'on voit que
depuis les années 2010 on part sur des
bases selon les méthodes de comptabilité
entre 30 et 50 € et que maintenant on
est entre et 70 et que les dans ce
rapport de la Cour des comptes il est
dit que la creux à la Commission des
comptes prennent toujours l'estimation
basse donc 50 et qu'aujourd'hui la creux
pour l'estimation haute 70 donc je
répète ma question le le les 5 milliards
d'investissement n'expliquent pas la
dérive des coûts donc en tant que
gestionnaire mandataire social comment
expliquez-vous cette dérive des coûts
que P systématiquement le contribuable
et les
entreprises monsieur
Tavel merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le le prédg deodf le député de
Loire Atlantique que je suis est
intéressé par deux questions
particulières l'une à laquelle vous
attendez sans doute qui est la
confirmation de l'engagement plein et
Antier deedf dans le projet de
conversion à la biomasse de la centrale
de cordemet d'ici à 2027 pouvez-vous
confirmer cet engagement ou préciser les
exigences notamment de soutien financier
public que vous attendez pour le faire
la deuxième concerne le développement de
l'éolien maritime le gouvernement a
indiqué récemment sa volonté d'empêcher
EDF d'emporter tous les appels d'offre
quand bien même il aurait la meilleure
offre à faire que pensez-vous de cette
discrimination
antiedf avez-vous l'intention de la
contester y compris de manière
judiciaire merci beaucoup monsieur
Stéphane
vogeta merci Monsieur le le président
j'en prfit d' d'abord pour un rapide
clin d'œil à à Monsieur Jumel qui qui
vient de m'enlever le monopole de la
citation de rappeur français au sein de
la commission des affaires économiques
donc MC solar succès d'aboba donc ça je
trouve ça très bien euh plus
sérieusement Monsieur Raymond je vous
pose une question en tant que que député
des Français de la péninsule ibérique et
très impliqué auprès de de nos acteurs
sur les interconnexions énergétiques euh
à propos du du projet d'interconnexion
électrique souterraine et sous-marine
entre la France et l'Espagne par le golf
de Gascogne un projet qui qui se
poursuit un projet conçu pour améliorer
la sécurité d'approvisionnement en
électricité et ma question est-elle donc
quant à l'implication de DF dans le
développement de cette infrastructure
êtes-vous impliqué directement ou
indirectement dans cette infrastructure
et dans les autres interconnexions
énergétiques et électrique entre la avec
la péninsule ibérique et quelle est
votre vision de l'importance stratégique
de de ces interconnexions pour
EDF merci beaucoup madame Marie Noë
bstel merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
juste une une petite question que
j'avais posée mais vous n'avez pas eu le
temps d'y répondre c'est concernant les
projets de d'augmentation de puissance
que vous avez déposé sur le bureau de la
ministre depuis déjà quelques mois
lorsque je l'avais interrogé récemment
elle m'avait dit normalement avant la
fin de l'année nous y sommes alors
est-ce qu'on aura la chance d'avoir un
cadeau de Noël avec une signature au
pied de la page pour que vous puissiez
engager des investissements c'est déjà
arrivé puisqu'on avait eu ça
je me rappelle 21 décembre 2010 pour
Romanche
gavé merci Monsieur Dominique petier et
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général je suis
heureux que Laurent Alexandre ait repris
la question que vous avez posée lors de
votre audition en vue de votre
nomination sur votre
rémunération merci de de ce relais on va
avoir enfin la réponse moi je voudrais
vous interroger sur l'agrivoltaïsme je
suis l'auteur de de l'amendement qui a
demandé un décret or aujourd'hui ce
décret je j'écouterai votre réponse à
postériori parisque j'ai rendez-vous
avec des membres du gouvernement
justement pour pour parler de ce sujet
très très délicat nous apprêtons à faire
un recours tant les dispositions
actuelles sont contraires à l'esprit de
ce que nous avions défendu en matière
d'équilibre entre la souveraineté
alimentaire la protection du droit du
sol et la production énergétique donc il
y a un vrai sujet aujourd'hui et moi
j'attendais que EDF j'attends que EDF
parce qu'on aime cette maison
profondément soit exemplaire et se
comporte pas comme des marchands de
soleil et puiss se déployer des modèles
économie sociale et territoriale
respectueux de l'agroécologie
respectueux de la politique
d'installation des agriculteurs et dans
ce qu'on va faire dans la ploa donc vous
devez montrer l'exemple avec d'autres
mais vous devz être les premiers
actuellement on ne le voit pas assez sur
le terrain merci Madame lblin merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général je sou
attirer votre attention sur le site de
production nucléaire de Chinon qui
depuis 60 ans fourn de l'électricité
pour le
territoire c'est important pour
économiquement un territoire et c'est la
raison pour laquelle les acteurs locaux
ont notamment participé et ont
souhaitait participer au au label
territoire d'industrie qu'ils ont porté
avec EDF et un certain nombre
d'associations des entreprises
prestataires pour autant le le dossier a
été rejeté donc il est vrai que il y a
aujourd'hui une forte incompréhension
une très forte déception et donc dans le
cadre de l'implantation de ces nouveaux
pr sinon apportant quand même un certain
nombre de de garanties et d'intérêts je
souhaitais connaître votre état d'esprit
l'état d'avancée de de ces travaux dans
la perspective de cette implantation
locale
merci merci beaucoup y y a-t-il
quelqu'un que j'ai oublié dans les
questions individuelles allez-y monsieur
Falcon
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le monsieur le PDG deedf c'est une
question de ma collègue Hélène la
pororte en avril dernier après un hiver
qui a mis à rue d'épreuve le système de
production électrique français la
ministre de la transition énergétique A
demandé à EDF de mettre à l'étude
l'augmentation de puissance ou upright
du parc nucléaire en effet dans la
plupart des pays disposant de réacteurs
nucléaires ceux-ci sont exploités sont
exploités à une puissance supérieure à
celle prévue lors de leur conception
c'est notamment le cas en Suède où des
gains de puissance allant jusqu'à 25 %
ont pu être réalisé sur des réacteurs
identiques aux nôtres en France l'idée
d'une surcapacité de notre parc puis la
politique de réduction de la production
nucléaire nous ont fait prendre un
retard hautement dommageable après la
fermeture irresponsable de 10,7 GW de
production pilotable depuis 2013 un
prate de l'ensemble de nos réacteurs
s'il ne s'effacerait pas s'il
n'effacerai pas les avirs passés
permettra un regain significatif de
capacité aussi nous aimerions
aujourd'hui nous vous demander où en
sont les études sur ce sujet je vous
remercie merci beaucoup pas d'autres
questions et donc je vous propose
monsieur le Président de couvrir ses
réponses une quinzaine de minutes si
c'est possible merci beaucoup merci
monsieur le Président merci mesdames et
messieurs les députés je vais essayer de
répondre de la façon la plus précise
possible tout en respectant le temps
indiqué par le président euh monsieur le
député travers sur la piscine donc phase
de consultation du
public a été réalisé nous avons eu un
certain nombre de retours dans le cadre
de cette consultation du public
notamment sur les conditions
d'intégration du chantier qui est
évidemment un élément absolument clé
donc nous travaillons sur ses retours à
ce
stade je pense que les conditions du
projet commencent maintenant à
s'affermir clairement et donc moi mon
objectif c'est que dès l'année prochaine
on enclenche une phase plus
opérationnelle du projet dans le respect
évidemment de l'ensemble des procédures
qui doivent être accompli il y a un une
demande d'autorisation de création qui
doit être qui doit être formulé il y a
l'ensemble des étapes qu'il faut
respecter mais le but c'est que nous
arrivions maintenant à une phase plus
opérationnelle de ce projet dans le
respect évidemment de l'intégration de
ce ce projet dans le territoire voilà
pour la
piscine Monsieur Madame Engrand pardon
il n'y a pas de de de demandefin de de
contrat d'écart
compensatoire ce ce que nous sommes
arrivés à déterminer avec le
gouvernement c'est un mécanisme dans
lequel le commerce de long terme permet
de faire attirer les prix et ensuite il
y a des seuils au-delà desquels les
revenus de DF sont captés pour permettre
une redistribution à l'ensemble des
consommateurs
d'électricité et pour les protéger d'une
éventuelle hausse des
prix monsieur Alexandre j'ai le plaisir
de vous donner la rémunération que je
connais désormais parce que je ne la
connaissais pas la dernière fois
effectivement voilà donc elle est de
450000 € brut
voilà c'est ma rémunération fixe je n'ai
je n'ai qu'une rémunération fixe
voil ensuite
monsieur Dubois sur euh le sur les
l'hydroélectricité ah pardon excusez-moi
je
je sur
l'hydroélectricité donc j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer devant devant
votre commission déjà il est clair que
nous devons là aussi réinventer régime
de l'hydroélectricité parce qu'il est
bloqué il est bloqué depuis longtemps
c'est le statut même des concessions qui
bloque les investissements donc il nous
faut trouver quelque chose qui permett
de relancer
l'investissement pour des raisons qui
sont à la fois hydroélectriques et de
gestion de la ressource en eau elles
sont électriques parce que
l'hydroélectricité est la meilleure
ressource commandable et nous avons
besoin de davantage de ressources
commandable électrique pour compenser
l'augmentation des ressources
intermittentes qui sont raccordées au
réseau chaque année le nucléaire il
contribue aussi mais l'hydroélectricité
est la meilleure pour ce profil et le
deuxième élément c'est que changement
climatique faisant il y a de plus en
plus de régions de France qui se
préoccupe à juste titre de la gestion
durable de la ressource en eau à
laquelle contribue évidemment une
gestion intelligente durable et
multi-usage des des retenus d'eau donc
pour cela il nous faut aller vers un
nouveau dispositif le régime des
autorisations est celui qui est adopté
par l'immense majorité des pays
européens qui ne sont pas bloqué dans
leurs investissements du fait d'avoir
choisi ce régime des autorisations et
donc notre proposition c'est de basculer
l'ensemble de l'hydroélectricité
française en tout cas pour tous les
opérateurs qui le souhaiteront vers ce
régime d'autorisation nous avons
énormément travaillé sur les conditions
juridique de cette bascule qui nous
paraissent tout à fait robuste et nous
sommes maintenant dans une phase dans
lequelle ce travail totalement partagé
bien sûr avec le gouvernement et les
administrations doit aller vers une
phase de décision et donc c'est ce que
nous proposons et ce que nous espérons
pour les mois qui viennent euh sur
euh sur les les aides et les factures je
vous remercie de m'interpeller hein sur
les sur les les factures euh pardon
prime énergie hein et je vais je vais
regarder ça avec mes équipes rapidement
euh bon je sais qu'à chaque fois qu'on a
des dispositifs d'ê comme ça ça engendre
en réalité ça je pense qu'il faut que la
représentation nationale soit consciente
une charge administrative énorme et une
complexité très importante et plus on
rajoute des éléments de
détermination contrôle et cetera et ca
plus on on crée une charge
administrative qui est très très
difficile à absorber donc merci de
m'avoir interpellé je vous reviendrai en
ayant fait le point précis avec mes
équipes sur ce sujet euh monsieur
euh pardon j'ai j'ai oublié euh monsieur
le député Rodwell oui bon évidemment
nous travaillons monsieur le député nous
travaillons maintenant de façon très
opérationnelle maintenant nous avons ce
cadre qui est fixé avec le gouvernement
nous avons les moyens maintenant de
travailler de façon très opérationnelle
et ça va prendre beaucoup d'ampleur à
partir du mois de janvier avec
l'ensemble des PME des ETI sur des
proposition opérationnelle que nos
concurrents pourront aussi
répliquer pour leur fournir des
conditions qui permettent d'atteindre
cette stabilité de long terme et c'est
vraiment ça qui est le l'élément le plus
déterminant on a bien conscience qu'il a
des situations particulières nous allons
faire tout ce que nous pouvons pour
traiter les cas précis individuels mais
le plus important c'est d'arriver à un
phénomène de masse sur l'ensemble du
marché électrique en le tirant vers le
long terme et pour ça nous aurons des
propositions opérationnelles à faire au
PME ETI à l'ensemble des entreprises dès
le mois de janvier
euh monsieur le député Benoît je crois
que j'ai
répondu monsieur mathazin alors c'est
évidemment un objectif pour EDF que de
permettre à l'ensemble des territoires
ultramarins d'aller vers le 100 %
renouvelable et et à ce titre d'ailleurs
les territoires ultramayens vont être en
avance sur la
métropole donc c'est c'est évidemment
c'est un défi que d'y arriver nous avons
avons des solutions technologiques pour
ça certaines sont déjà en cours de
déploiement j'ai le plaisir de vous dire
que la réunion sera le premier
territoire ultram à être 100 %
renouvelable grâce au passage au
bioliquide de la centrale
thermique qui qui qui opère déjà la
Guyane sera le deuxè grâce à la centrale
de larivo qui est en cours de
construction désormais et donc
progressivement avec un un programme qui
doit être défini territoire par
territoire nous allons arriver à aller
vers le 100 % renouvelable grâce
notamment parce qu'il faut garder de la
capacité commandable et donc la seule
capacité commandable que nous puissions
mettre dans les territoires ultramarins
et du thermique décarboné et donc grâce
notamment au bioliquide et donc nous
nous créons dans ces dans ces
territoires grâce à ces territoires nous
créons une filière de bioliquide qui
répond évidemment à tous les critères de
durabilité qui sont souhaités par par le
groupe EDF sur l'agrivoltaïsme vous avez
été plusieurs à m'interpeller sur le
vololtaïsme nous nous souhaitons
évidemment étudier
l'acroltaïsme en tant queopérateur
responsable donc nous avons aujourd'hui
essentiellement de la
Red qui nous permet de d'avoir des tests
à la fois sur nos propres sites et puis
sur des sites agricoles dans lequel nous
allons observer pendant plusieurs années
l'effet de l'agrivoltaïsme sur le plan
électrique bien sûr mais surtout sur le
plan agricole euh pour voir si il y a
des effets néfastes ou bénéfiques sur
les récoltes sur la soutenabilité de
l'activité et donc nous avons
actuellement des parcelles en test avec
une parcelle témoins et une parcelle qui
est équipée d'agrivoltaïsme à côté de
Bordeaux qui va nous permettre de voir
si les mêmes raisins les mêmes les mêmes
conditions d'ensoleillement avec d'un
côté évidemment des panneaux solaires
qui ne captent pas la totalité de la
lumière et de l'autre une parcelle qui
est totalement vierge de toute
couverture voir ce que ça donne sur
plusieurs années on peut pas juger ça
sur une seule une seule année et on a
les mêmes exercices sur nos propres
parcelles de Red pour pouvoir déterminer
de façon vraiment scientifique ce qu'il
est possible d'attendre et une fois
qu'on aura des éléments probants en la
matière naturellement nous les
partagerons et je pense ça nous
permettra d'aborder ce sujet de façon
durable en attendant il est clair que en
matière de photovoltaïque il y a
tellement à faire sur les les zones
artificialisées que nous il nous semble
que nous focaliser sur les zones
artificialisées et et sans doute le
chemin le plus pragmatique pour aller
chercher de la puissance complémentaire
et dans tous les territoires il y a
beaucoup de surfaces artificialisées
disponibles à cette fin euh euh monsieur
le député Jumel euh sur le projet de la
CNR c'est le projet de la CNR par
définition il fait partie de son contrat
de concession naturellement il y a des
questions de coordination avec le projet
du budget nous sommes en contact avec la
CNR pour en discuter pour vérifier que
euh la coordination des deux projets n'a
pas d'impact négatif sur l'un ou sur
l'autre il y a du travail devant nous
donc je peux pas vous donner en détail
ce qu'il en ressortira mais en tout cas
nous sommes en contact avec les équipes
de la CNR pour déterminer quel est le
calendrier adapté de l'un et de l'autre
contrepartie en faveur de
l'électrification des usages bah par
définition et je crois que vous le savez
pour nous un un projet d'équipement de
production électrique dans dans un
territoire c'est un projet de territoire
donc il est clair que il nous faut
travailler alors en tant queedf parce
que les capacités deedf ne sont pas
illimité et surtout ces responsabilités
sont sont définies pour faire en sorte
que l'ancrage dans le territoire de ce
projet soit le meilleur possible mais je
sais que les services de l'État le
préfet notamment dans le casre de la
région d'où vous venez sont totalement
mobilisés pour faire un de ce du projet
de P lit en l'occurrence mais de tout
projet de même nature un succès pour le
territoire et c'est bien dans cet état
esprit que DF travaillera
euh monsieur euh euh monsieur le député
Pinot euh nous évidemment la sécurité
d'approvisionnement c'est notre c'est
c'est notre principale préoccupation et
nous nous y travaillons et nous
travaillons dans cette perspective
l'horizon 2030 c'est celui auquel nous
pouvons compter sur une accélération du
renouvelable une accélération du
renouvelable décentralisée don je pense
on sous-estime l'accélération
aujourd'hui
ce qu'on appelle renouvelable
décentralisé c'est notamment le solaire
photovoltaïque sur toiture qui va faire
x 2 d'une année sur l'autre donc c'est
un élément très important d'une
augmentation de production renouvelable
certes de pic certes intermittente mais
néanmoins d'une capacité de production
électrique qui sera disponible en masse
à l'horizon
2030 tout ce que nous pourrons faire
d'ici là pour augmenter la puissance du
parc c'est un horizon 200 30 aussi
notamment sur les réacteurs 900 MW qui
nécessitent pas de faire autre chose que
de toucher le réseau secondaire j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure sur la
question d'augmentation de puissance
donc nous avons des leviers sur euh la
le renforcement de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement d'ici 2030 et
naturellement nous allons aller les
chercher il faut jamais oublier le
levier du côté de la consommation et
c'est pour ça que vous entendrez
toujours EDF parler de sobriété
d'efficacité énergétique un des leviers
principaux parce que dans notre pays
comme ailleurs la quantité d'électricité
ou la quantité d'énergie plus simplement
qui est qui est utilisée alors qu'elle
pourrait être sauvée d'une certaine
manière reste extrêmement importante ça
fait partie des éléments de notre
sécurité
énergétique monsieur le député
Vigier merci pour votre question sur sur
l'hydroélectricité euh le potentiel est
important sur
l'hydroélectricité il commence par par
les barrages existants sur les barrages
existants nous avons la capacité de de
de nous avons la capacité de faire plus
sur les barrages existant ça suppose
principalement que nous ayons dépassé le
blocage juridique dans lequel nous
sommes à partir du moment où nous
l'aurions dépassé nous serons en mesure
de relancer une politique qui peut aller
de la petite hydro à la grande
hydroélectricité et qui concourra à à la
à la sécurité d'approvisionnement et
également aux
capacités de de d'équilibrage du réseau
dont nous avons impérativement besoin
euh monsieur le député
[Musique]
l'pinot je vous remercie de me qualifier
d'un défenseur d'un opposant
consommateur je ne pense pas que ce soit
ce qui définit la mission d'EDF EDF est
là pour assurer ou la perception pardon
dans ce caslà c'est moi qui est mal
compris la mission de def c'est
d'apporter de l'électricité compétitive
à nos concitoyens aujourd'hui et demain
aujourd'hui et demain donc si nous le
faisions aujourd'hui dans des conditions
qui sont insoutenables sur le plan
économique demain nous ne serions pas en
mesure d'accomplir notre mission et donc
c'est une tâche difficile que de dire
voilà aujourd'hui il nous faut avoir un
un niveau de prix de l'électricité qui
soit soutenable pour tout le monde mais
c'est quand même notre responsabilité
que d'être capable de dire il nous faut
être capable d'investir les fameux 25
milliards d'euros par an pour faire en
sorte que en 2030 2035 2040 2045 no
concitoyens puissent continuer de
bénéficier de suffisamment d'électricité
et dans des conditions compétitives dans
le temps et c'est bien comme ça que nous
concevons notre mission donc oui à très
court terme peut-être que de temps en
temps ça peut
paraître difficile de dire on aimerait
que ce soit moins cher oui c'est
possible mais il vaut mieux que ce soit
soutenable aujourd'hui et demain plutôt
que de passer par des m dans lequel nous
traversons une vraie crise
d'approvisionnement monsieur lénet euh
merci pour votre question sur les SMR
donc les SMR sont son un type de
réacteur qui seront
nécessairire à l'échelle internationale
probablement d'abord à l'échelle
internationale par rapport à besoins
français mais avec un véritable
potentiel permettant de répondre à des
besoins même en France sur des besoins
spécifiques soit dans des situations de
péninsule énergétique nous en avons même
en France soit dans des situations de
besoins industriels spécifiques qui
peuvent émerger en France ou qui peuvent
exister en France nous avons un projet
qui est le projet New World euh dont le
but est d'être prêt à construire en 2030
euh et qui est en Phe de définition
préliminaire pour l'instant euh c'est un
projet qui repose sur des technologies
que nous connaissons puisque c'est un
réacteur à haut pressurisé selon la même
technologie que celle des gros réacteurs
et nous sommes en train de le développer
avec je dois dire une un niveau de
collaboration européenne qui est tout à
fait exemplaire puisque l'objectif c'est
d'avoir ce réacteur disponible pas juste
pour la France mais pour d'autres
marchés et nous avons une collaboration
eurne tout à fa fait exemplaire y
compris entre les autorités de sûreté
d'un certain nombre de pays qui
approchent la définition de ce réacteur
dans le cadre de groupe de travail
commun
euh monsieur le député
Borgeot merci pour votre interpéation
sur les prime énergie et la pompe à
chaleur je vous reviendrai comme indiqué
précédemment monsieur le député
Tangi merci de m'interpeller sur le
rapport de la Cour des comptes et sur
les références de coûts que vous avez
évoqué
euh une entreprise elle est pas pilotée
par ses coûts comptables euh quand vous
prenez un appareil industriel qui est
amorti parce queil a été construit il y
a 30 ans si vous considérez que vous
devez vendre au coût comptable d'un
appareil industriel amorti il y a 30 ans
vous ne générez pas les revenus qui
permettent de régénérer cet appareil
industriel et donc il y a pas
d'inflation des coûts en tant que tel il
y a simplement la nécessité pour EDF
d'avoir une économie qui est fondée sur
la pérenité de son activité donc
naturellement EDF doit travailler sur
ces coups pour qu'il soit compétitif et
c'est mon engagement et c'est ma
responsabilité que de le faire mais on
peut pas non plus comparer des coûts
comptables qui qui simplement sont issu
de l'amortissement d'une valeur qui a
été défin dans les années 80 pour
déterminer à quel coût de moyen terme ou
quel coût économique on doit définir
l'électricité pour aujourd'hui et donc
c'est bien cet équilibre là qu'il faut
trouver monsieur le député Tavel
merci de votre question sur cord deem
donc nous avons aujourd'hui l'engagement
d'opérer cord deem jusqu'en 2027 avec 20
% de de boî pet puis qui est compatible
avec la technologie qui est présente
technologie de chauffe qui est présente
sur la centrale de corord deem nous
avons des études qui du travail en cours
sur la période
2027-2030 qui nécessite là aussi des
questions de faisabilité technique et
économique évidemment des discussions
sur la façon dont nous approvisionnons
les Pelet sur cette période là sur le
plus long terme il y a également du
travail économique qui est nécessaire
pour déterminer les conditions dans
lesquelles la centrale de cordemet
pourrait opérer au-delà de 2030 en tout
état de cause le site de cordemet est
absolument stratégique pour EDF pour de
la production c'est clair et donc nous
aurons l'ensemble des études qui vont se
poursuivre avec le but d'arriver avec à
des conclusion ion dans les dans les
mois ou dans l'année qui vient et
également des travaux sur les différents
moyens de production qui sont
potentiellement déployable à cordomet en
dehors ou en plus de l'activité qui est
égal qui est en place
aujourd'hui nous je passe à la question
de Monsieur vogetta
EDF n'est pas impliqué sur sur les
travaux d'interconnexion entre la France
et l'Espagne c'est le travail du RTE et
donc euh
donc naturellement nous suivons avec
intérêt ces développements parce que les
interconnexions en G permettent de
renforcer la résilience du réseau
électrique européen et donc la faculté
de nous échanger physiquement de
l'électricité à des moments où soit
l'Espagne soit la France en aurait
besoin l'Espagne est un territoire qui a
de plus en plus d'intermittence puisque
ils vont progressivement fermer leur
centrale nucléaire et ils ont une
production renouvelable très importante
et donc évidemment l'intercon tion pour
l'Espagne est est un est un projet
important madame
btistel les projets d'augmentation de
puissance je pense que vous faisiez
référence à vouglan probablement et
d'autres écoutez on on est en phase
avancée sur tous ces projets moi je
souhaite qu'ils aillent le plus vite
possible c'est clair et donc j'ai bon
espoir qu'on avance je ne sais pas vous
dire si c'est d'ici la fin de l'année ou
non parce qu'il y a un certain nombre de
décisions qui qui voilà moi je donc
faisons confiance à la ministre voilà en
tout cas c'est ces quelques projets sont
les seuls qu'on arrive à sortir dans ind
déépendamment du blocage juridique
auquel on est confronté donc ils sont
vraiment très importants j'espère qu'on
arrive à déplacer à dépasser le blocage
juridique pour qu'on puisse en faire
émerger d'autres et le potentiel est
important dans notre
pays monsieur
potier bon sur l'agriovoltaisme je crois
que j'ai répondu notre souci à nous
c'est de d' arriver à définir de façon
scientifique quelles sont les bonnes
conditions d'un agrivoltaïsme raisonné
qui serait bon d'un point de vue
agricole il peut y avoir des cas dans
lesquels c'est ça l'IT mais nous
travaillons avec des spécialistes ce qui
n'est pas le cas de DF nous ne sommes
pas nous ne sommes pas un institut de
recherche agronomique donc nous
travaillons avec des instituts de
recherche agronomique pour en déterminer
les conditions euh madame Blin merci
beaucoup pour votre question sur la
centrale de Chinon et sur le sur sur le
le le bassin d'emploi de Chinon je
comptais m'y rendre au mois de novembre
malheureusement nous avions beaucoup de
discussions en cours et donc je n'ai pas
pu m'y rendre mais c'est reprogrammé dès
le mois de février je crois voilà j'ai
pas la date en tête mais en tout cas
j'ai prévu de m'y rendre il est clair
que pour nous c'est un des territoires
importants avec du potentiel du
savoir-faire on y a évidemment enfin je
je vais raisonner sur sur la région au
sens plus large hein on y a beaucoup de
savoir-faire on y a une partie notre
ingénierie aussi et puis évidemment des
opérations nucléaires donc donc ça fait
partie des territoires que je n'ai pas
encore eu l'occasion de visiter depuis
ma prise de fonction mais c'est
programmé et naturellement nous avons un
objectif de développement sur ce
territoire
euh monsieur Falcon merci pour votre
question sur l'augmentation de puissance
donc on est au-delà des études nous nous
nous souhaitons maintenant passer à la
mise en œuvre sur l'augmentation de
puissance en commençant notamment par
les réacteurs de 900 MW parce que comme
je l'indiquis tout à l'heure pour les
réacteurs de 900 MW nous pouvons
réaliser l'augmentation de puissance en
changeant simplement le secondaire c'est
sans sans implication sur le circuit
primaire et donc avec des conditions
relativement simples et donc nous
commencerons par ces réacteurs voilà
j'espère que je n'ai rien oublié et si
tel est le cas j'espère que j'ai rien
oublié voilà merci infiniment merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président merci
pour la qualité de vos réponses et le
temps que vous nous avez consacré ce
matin et merci à vos vos équipes qui
étaient également présentes chers
collègues je vous propose une suspension
de 5 minutes et nous enchaînons sur la
question des entrepôts à tout de suite